until the end of the Bill's Passage and
the minister for women inequalities
corresponded with and met with the
cabinet secretary Shona Robertson to
discuss the UK government's concerns
Before the bill had reached his final
stage
Mr Speaker I have not taken this
decision lightly
the government
principally at the potential impact of
the and I've considered all relevant
in operational implications together
with the minister for women inequalities
and it is our assessment that the bill
would have a serious adverse impact
among other things on the operation of
the equality act 2010. those adverse
effects include impacts on the operation
of single sex clubs associations and
schools and protections such as equal
pay
the government serves the concerns of
many members of the public and Civic
Society groups regarding the potential
impact of the bill on women and girls
the bill also risks creating significant
complications from having two different
gender recognition regimes in the UK and
allowing more fraudulent or bad faith
applications
the government is today publishing a
full statement of reasons alongside the
order which will set in full the adverse
effects the government is concerned
about
Mr Speaker I would like to address the
claims put forward by those who would
seek to politicize this decision and
fame and claim that this is some kind of
constitutional outrage and you can hear
them Mr Speaker you can hear them the
section 35 par was included in the
Scotland act which established the
Scottish Parliament this is the first
time the power has been exercised and I
acknowledge that this is a significant
decision that powers of section 35 of
the Scotland actor not new and this
government has not created them they
have existed as long as Devolution
itself and we should be clear that the
power was included in the act by The
Architects of the Devolution for a
reason Donald Drew himself noted that
the power struck an important balance
the section 35 power provides a sensible
measure to ensure that evolved
legislation does not have adverse
impacts on reserve matters including on
the equalities legislation such as the
equality Act 2010.
this is not about preventing the
Scottish Parliament from legislating on
devault Badgers but about ensuring that
we do not have legal Frameworks in one
part of the United Kingdom which have
adverse effects on reserve matters and
we should be clear that this is
absolutely not about the United Kingdom
government being able to veto Scottish
Parliament legislation whenever it
chooses as some as some have implied the
power can only be exercised on specific
grounds and the fact that this is the
first time it has been necessary to
exercise the parent almost 25 years of
devolution emphasizes that it is not a
power to be used lightly
in the instance of the gender
recognition reform Scotland bill I have
concluded that the bill would have
serious adverse effects on the operation
of the equality act 2010 and as I've set
out of my correspondence with the first
Minister yesterday I prefer not to be in
this situation the United Kingdom
government does all we can to respect
the Devolution settlement and to resolve
disputes it is open to the Scottish
government to bring back an amended bill
for reconsideration in the Scottish
Parliament so to conclude Mr Speaker I
have set out to the Scottish government
that they should that should they choose
to do so I hope we can work together to
find a constructive way forward that
both respect Evolution and the operation
of the United Kingdom Parliament
legislation and I commend this statement
to the house I call The Shadow Secretary
of State in Murray thank you Mr Speaker
can I thank the Secretary of State for
advanced sight of his statement this is
a an incredibly serious moment it's the
first time section 35 has been invoked
Donald dure has already been mentioned
the father of devolution of course
designed section 35 to protect Evolution
it was passed by all parties in this
house and hasn't been objected to since
it was intended not as a blocking
mechanism but an enabling mechanism so
the Scottish Parliament could pass
legislation and devolve competencies
without changing reserved functions
there was concern at the time by
colleagues of the secretary of state
that this could be used as a veto so a
member of understanding a memorandum of
understanding was agreed it said and I
quote although the UK government is
prepared to use these Powers if
necessary it sees them as very much a
matter of Last Resort the UK government
and the administration concerned will
therefore aim to resolve any
difficulties through discussion so as to
avoid any action or a mission by the
devolved Administration having an
adverse impact on non-devolved matters
so can I ask the secretary of state is
this a last resort
has the secretary of state had extensive
discussions with the Scottish government
before taking this action how many times
has the Secretary of State met the
Scottish government Before the bill was
passed during its debate in Hollywood
and since its Passage
it appears to me that this has only
become a last resort in terms of the
legal timing because both governments
can't and won't work with each other
the secretary of state says the section
35 is being used among other reasons in
relation to the equality act both the
Scotland act and their Courtyard are
Landmark pieces of Labor legislation
establishing the evolution and
entraining rights to be free of
discrimination and law nobody has to
question this party's commitment to
equality we we passed the initial gra we
brought in the disability Discrimination
Act and we've got the world leading
equality act into law but clearly
there's a need for laws passed by
Hollywood and those by Westminster to
interact
and in this case the trans Community
need that cross-border interaction to
work
after 25 years of devolution section 35
has never been exercised as largely
because of the way Devolution was set up
and intended to operate governments with
their own agendas but with a common
purpose working together to serve the
Scottish people now Scotland is saddled
with an Administration in Edinburgh
that's hell-bent on breaking Devolution
and a conservative Administration here
in London that's intent on ignoring it
indeed the Secretary of State seems to
spend more time with government lawyers
to stop things happening rather than
make them work and the Scottish
government is spending hundreds of
thousands of pounds on lawyers
challenging laws they know are
unchallengeable in order to manufacture
political grievance and in this case
it's the public who are let down
trans people who suffer intense
discrimination will now not see this
legislation take effect anytime soon if
at all and women's rights groups who
likely will likely not see their
concerns address or their fears
alleviated because this simple truth is
that this has turned into a
constitutional Bond fate
I would also suggest that the s p would
be rightly screaming and they are doing
today and would do so in the past if a
piece of legislation passed in this
place had implication for default
competencies they would challenge that
and they would greatly challenge that as
is the right
and if we are to accept the argument
from the Scottish government that there
is no effect on the equality act then
the courts will surely strike out the
section 35 action as we believe the
Scottish government will take it to
court
Mr Speaker can I also ask the Secretary
of State Scottish labor got the Primacy
of the equality act on the face of the
gender recognition bill will the statue
instrumentally he detailed in his
statement give the details of where he
thinks it is incompatible the Secretary
of State said last night there was a
version of this act which the UK
government could support so what does
that look like
but he says in his statement there are
complications with two different gender
regimes is he saying the Scottish
Parliament shouldn't have the competence
as the bill was debated in Hollywood was
it not obvious to him
and to his colleagues that it could
contravene Reserve law what did he do
about it then
during the passage of the bill Scottish
labor made clear that if the bill was to
work clear guidance was required
the SMP Scottish government said it was
for the equality and Human Rights
Commission to provide such guidance not
them as the government
why didn't the Secretary of State
instruct the ehrc to provide that
guidance look at the cross-border issues
he mentions and provide recommendations
as to the interaction of the equality
act both governments should commit to
accepting those conclusions or is the
Secretary of State saying that the ball
is only in the Scottish government's
Court to bring back amended legislation
and he now backs out of the process Mr
Speaker we support the principle of
updating the GRE
which
[Music]
which when the labor government
introduced in 2004 was World leading but
two decades on now requires
modernization to humanize and to remove
the indignities in this Dreadful process
We've Ended up in a legal and
constitutional impasse my final question
to the secretary of state is what is he
going to do to resolve it yeah
well Mr Speaker
um to ask his questions Hope from the
right order it is it is not a last
resort to understand the Scotland act
the section 33 is where the UK
legislation is is directly changed and
section 35 is when it's adversely
affected and we have 28 days to make a
decision either the case before the
legislation goes for Royal assented in
this case the test the legal test that
has been given to us and proved by our
officials is one of section 35 which is
adverse effect on the uh on two parts of
UK of UK stroke GB legislation so that's
that that's where we're at we have 28
days to make that decision and we have
to make a decision in that time frame
and in this case the series The the this
very senior legal opinion advises us
that as section 35 is appropriate and we
will see that in my statement of reasons
which we have laid uh with the order
on his second Point
um officials have been meeting with
officials in the Scottish government
since the bill was introduced and the
minister for gender inequalities wrote
after the second stage wrote to the bill
Minister uh expressing her concerns and
asking for a meeting and that meeting
took place and again her concerns were
expressed at that meeting regarding uh
the aehrc
the HRC have said that they're willing
to support or to work with and support
the Scottish government if they can
however they make it very clear that
their ongoing concerns are still on the
record and that's where that rests and I
think that addresses all the points that
he raised
well he but if if if any are not
addressed I'm sure others in the chamber
will ask those questions
Douglas rolls
just the outlined in his statement how
the UK government has sought to
constructively engage with the Scottish
government during the passage of this
bill prior to it being voted on in the
Scottish Parliament yet Nicholas
sturgeon has now tried to turn this into
a political battle between the Scottish
and UK government when all as I
understand it the Scottish sector and
the government are trying to do is
protect women's rights so despite
despite the holes that we are getting
from the SMP can the Scottish secretary
confirm that can the Scottish secretary
confirm that all the SMP have to do is
bring forward a bill in the Scottish
Parliament that protects the rights of
women and girls across the United
Kingdom
yes yes and actually I think that Mr
Speaker fortunately that addresses one
of the points that I that the shadow
Secretary of State for Scotland raised
and I can address that here I mean I
have written to the first Minister I've
suggested uh that we meet to resolve
these issues and it is the case that the
the bill the Scottish government's bill
has adverse effects on those two pieces
of Scottish Association you will see it
in the statement of reasons which the
the those have been produced by our
legal advisors and what is missing is is
sufficient protections and safeguards
for women and children that are
reflected in existing Westminster
legislation and that is why I have had
to lay this order we now come to SMP
spokesperson Dr Philippa Whitford thank
very much Mr Speaker vetoing this
legislation is an unprecedented attack
on the Scottish Parliament which passed
the gender recognition Reform Bill
86-39 including msps from every single
party gender recognition is a devolved
policy area and this does not change the
2010 equality act or give any additional
rights to those with a certificate it
shortens and simplifies the process and
particularly ends the requirement for a
psychological diagnosis of gender
dysphoria this is in keeping with the
guidance from the World Health
Organization and un which recommends
change to a legal statutory process
based on self-identification this change
has already been made by many countries
over the last decade including neighbors
Ireland Belgium Denmark this government
is threatening to end UK acceptance of
international certificates I find it
bizarre considering the former prime
minister the right honorable member for
maidenhead suggested a similar proposal
in 2017. so can the Secretary of State
explain exactly which parts of the
equality act are changed by this bill
why did he not raise specific concerns
during the two consultations carried out
by the Scottish Parliament or in
response to the cabinet secretaries
letter in October rather than a response
that came three days before the final
debate on the bill
what modifications is he suggesting to
the bill that wouldn't include a return
to the outmoded medicalized process why
is he using one of the most marginalized
groups in society to pick a fight with a
Scottish Parliament
is he seriously is he seriously after
300 years of different marriage ages and
voting ages suggesting there can no
longer be legal or age differences North
and South of the Border and does he
recognize that vetoing this bill simply
highlights the hollow reality of
devolution
well Mr Speaker The Honorable lady won't
be surprised to hear that I don't
recognize very much of what she said has
been correct and I would Point her to I
would Point her to the statement of
reasons which will be laid alongside
this order today today today
which will which and it's and and our
legal advice is very clear the equality
act 2010 is reserved and there are
adverse effects there are adverse
effects and they will be there in the
statement of reasons and I and and I I
listed some of those in my in my
statement I made only moments ago I
listed them areas around
associations Women's Safe spaces
single-size clubs essential set schools
Etc et cetera it was very clear it was
very clear what I said and you will see
what legal counsel have determined when
you see the statement of reasons
yeah Laura Faris
[Applause]
thank you very much Mr Speaker a
conservative government standing up for
women's sex-based rights
I congratulate the government on this
decision which we know will protect
Women's Specialists sex-based specialist
services in areas like Rape Crisis
but does he
shouting but does he agree with me given
the verdict of the UN special raffle to
her given the verdict of Dr Hillary Cass
which is not yet complete it is
essential that every corner of the
United Kingdom reads and reaches an
agreed position on the age limit for
agenda recognition certificate
shot
this is the single biggest attack on
Scottish Devolution and Scottish
democracy since the establishment of the
Scottish parliament in 1999. a move to
state that a piece of legislation which
is supported by every single party in
the parliament is as provocative as
anti-democratic when the Scotland act
went through Parliament back in 1998 the
conservatives then called section 35 the
colonial General
and as he know the real life Colonial
General imposing his view on a reluctant
Scottish parliament in the name of his
and his party's culture wars
Mr Speaker I come back to my original
point this is a decision I I didn't take
it lightly it was after much
consideration of the legal advice that
we received and and and it is based on a
section 35 order which is in the 1998
Scotland act an act that was brought
forward by the labor party uh Led Led
through Parliament by Donald Joe and
voted for by the Scottish national party
you're gonna be right thank you very
much Mr Speaker isn't the Central Point
here that Devolution is not the same as
Independence and in every devolution
to the discipline
some I accept but in every Devolution
settlement including arrows every
devolved legislature has to legislate
with consideration for the other parts
of the United Kingdom
if that does not happen section 35 is
the appropriate instrument for the UK
government to consider the use of and
isn't the visceral reaction to the
government's temerity and even
considering the use of section 35 where
there are clear conflicts between the
devolve approach and the UK approach a
demonstration that there is no
acceptance on the part of the SNP of the
Devolution settlement at all
right here well my
um learned right honorable friend is
absolutely right I mean Devolution is
about granting Parts not giving Powers
away and not seeding powers and that is
that is what the Devolution act does
that Westminster Westminster through the
Devolution act gave powers to the
Scottish Parliament but the Act was very
clear it kept section 33 and section 35
for when there were conflicts and a
conflict has arisen here in the case of
adverse effects towards uk-wide
legislation in the in the terms of the
two acts that will be referred to in the
statement of reasons
thank you Mr Speaker the Secretary of
State claims that there is a version of
this bill that the UK government will
accept and indeed it's been noted by the
chair of the women inequalities Select
Committee in this place that the bill is
broadly in line with the recommendations
made by their committee following their
inquiry into the gender recognition act
can the minister explain why he did not
work together with counterparts in
Hollywood to avoid this unnecessary and
unprecedented constitutional collision
and will the minister now make a
statement here in this house as to what
reform to the gra the government will
make across the UK if they're seeking to
block progressive reform in Scotland
well I'd say to The Honorable lady that
I am doing the Constitutional part here
my role as Secretary of State for
Scotland and the section 35 order is
where the legal advice has taken me the
minister who's on the bench the minister
for gender inequalities will deal with
the policy and it's very and you should
you should absolutely raise your point
with her
they have Fox surely thank you Mr
Speaker there are many in the house who
will agree with the content of the
Scottish government's bill
and there are many in the house I have
to say including myself who will object
to the contents but that is not the
point at issue here today we live in a
unitary state to have different gender
recognition certification processes in
different parts of the United Kingdom
are likely to produce conflict and
confusion does my right honorable friend
agree that it was never part of the
Devolution settlement that any one part
of devolved government across the United
Kingdom could effectively change or
require a change for Citizens across the
whole of our unitary Nation
I absolutely agree Mr Speaker yeah
yeah the field
does the bill clearly conflicts with the
equality act and would have
repercussions for women
feeling amongst women women's rights
groups and activists in Scotland that
this bill seeks to allow anyone at all
to to legally self-identify as either
sex and therefore enter all spaces
including those necessarily segregated
by sex such as domestic violence
settings changing rooms in prisons and
given the previous uq doesn't you not
understand how vitally important this is
at the moment
Mr Mr Deputy speaker I think I think the
honorable lady deserves a lot of respect
for her courage and standing up on this
issue and and I think when when the
statement of reasons is read later today
she will be proved to be absolutely
right in the things she's saying
thank you
speaker having served as a minister in
the Scotland office alongside my right
honorable friend for a couple of years I
know how compassionately and diligently
he has looked into these matters uh it
is a complex issue there are lots of
consequences but do we not owe it to
everyone to look at these matters
dispassionately to work through the
points of conflict and turn the dial
down on some of the heat that's been
generated
but
my honorable friend's absolutely right
the tone is very important in these
matters and it is not a decision uh that
I've taken lightly it is after due
consideration of the legal advice
received and yes let's take the heat out
of these matters let's deal with the
legal issues and then see if there's a
resolution we can find
thank you Mr adapt
wide consultation
two-thirds of msp's supporting the
legislation in support from msps from
every single political party in the
Scottish Parliament the SNP the
conservatives the labor party and the
liberal Democrats yet these actions from
the Tory government are shameful and
they're actually quite scary so this is
Secretary of State for Scotland share my
concerns that list decision so it's a
dangerous precedent where Westminster
dictates in Hollywood must simply shut
up and do as they are told
no no Mr Deputy speaker obviously I
don't you know in 24 years the Scottish
Parliament has passed 347 acts the
Scottish government is the the the
United Kingdom government has never used
the section 35 act in that time it has
been deemed the legal advice has been
deemed that we should should use at this
time and that is what we've done because
there are adverse effects on uk-wide
legislation Leonard Jenkins uh thank you
Mr Deputy speaker can I point out to my
right honorable friend that as
spokesman of position spokesman on the
Devolution bills when they were passing
through Parliament in 1988 I took part
in the debate where the question of the
Devolution of equality Rights was
explicitly debated I pointed out that
anti-discrimination laws have to be
handled with great care because it is
all too easy to substitute one type of
intolerance of minorities for another
and that is exactly what the s p act
does by denying the rights of women and
girls but the important point is that
the labor spokesman one of the
architects of devolution Henry mcleish
responded that the human rights might be
devolved but equal equal opportunities
should not be devolved that they should
not be able to that the Scottish
Parliament should not be able to and
quote that they should not be able to
impose new duties or additional
regulation in equal opportunities
matters it was expressly debated in the
House of Commons it was very it on in
the House of Commons and the s p lost
their Amendment on that topic isn't it
time for now for the SNP to respect the
evolution settlement and can he write
today can you write to the official
opposition and ask them exactly what
their response to his statement means
why have the architects of devolution
been replaced by weasels
[Applause]
Mr Deputy speaker
we are we are fortunate to have a
colleague of such great political
sagacity amongst us who was there when
the legislation was brought forward and
and and and and he he is right it was
vote it was voted for as a democratic
bill that went through this Parliament
supported by all parties
and that is that is the instrument
section 35 that we're using today is
part of that bill that was brought
forward by the labor party and supported
by the Scottish national party back in
1998.
thank you Mr Deputy speaker know
whatever your views about the gender
recognition Reform Bill Nicholas
sturgeon's obsession with Independence
has clouded her judgment and she is
showing disregard for the rest of the
United Kingdom and its laws
it is our own party that voted in favor
of section 35 been included in the
Scotland act the rights of women and
other vulnerable groups should not be
Pawns in her constitutional gameplay
does the Secretary of State agree with
me that invoking section 35 of the
Scotland Act is deeply unfortunate but
however necessary because the gr bill
has not taken due consideration in
uk-wide laws and that is in fact it is
Nicholas sturgeon that is failing to
respect Evolution and the uk-wide
equality act with her dangerous actions
speaker I absolutely agree with the
honorable lady I thank her for her
comments we we do not believe and it'll
be in the statement of reasons that
there is sufficient protections and
safeguards in the grr bill for women and
children
uh Mr Deputy speaker as a committed
unionist like every member on this side
of the house but also one that respects
the Devolution settlement
the principle of one legislature
intervening on another legislature could
set a significant and serious precedent
so can my right honorable friend
reassure me that the reason he is using
the section 35 order is because of
specific legal concerns because of the
impact of that legislation on all parts
of the United Kingdom including Scotland
rather than for any other political
means seeking to undermine the evolution
yes
yes Alan Brown thank you master Deputy
speaker when we hear talker agreed
positions across the UK with the Tory
right Winger's main Scotland does your
tail and the labor MPS are in tears from
these guys over there worrying about
look at themselves but after six years
of consultation and discussions
um about the grr about when did the
secretary said when this government
suddenly discover that equal pay is
somehow threatened by it and what is the
problem we compared that he says under
threat
well the the minister for women
inequalities raised that subject with
the bill Minister and it you it will be
explained in our statement of reasons
the adverse effects are numerous are
numerous and and if you read the adverse
of estate if you read the uh statement
you will see those points
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I believe
that the Liberties and responsibilities
of all citizens across the four nations
of the United Kingdom are equal which is
why amongst other things I keenly
supported the extension of same-sex
marriage to Northern Ireland now I share
the concerns about the rights of
biological women to Single Sex spaces
but I'm most concerned about the
capacity of children miners to determine
their own gender and embark on
potentially life-changing physical
Transformations this dispute has been
confected by the SMP in pursuit of their
separatist agenda so does my right honor
of a friend agree then it really is
shameful that they have weaponized
vulnerable children in Pursuit
of that agenda I would impose that
agenda on the majority of children
across the whole United Kingdom
yes Tony Smith thank you Mr Deputy
speaker when they finished thank you Mr
Deputy speaker in my role on the public
affairs Constitution Affairs committee I
have with others been around the United
Kingdom on scrutiny in the operation of
devolution of which I'm a strong
supporter the state of relationships
between the Tories and the SNP is
deleterious and it's damaging all our
rights the SNP went to court to argue
that sex was a legal construct not a
biological construct and therefore has
landed Us in this position and they are
trading on people's rights it's
outrageous they are disregarding
sex-bake rights which is exactly
it's not acceptable for people to stand
up to talk about women's sex baits
rights and to be constantly badgered
let us speak equally don't accept
barracking from the men in the corner
over there
what we need to know now and it'd be
helpful to have the reasons before going
forward is what exactly the UK
government who has not discussed this in
advance of this coming here before and
behaved outrageously what exactly are
they expecting the SNP Scottish
government to do to help the rights of
transgender people and women
when we have reservations well
um I won't go into the details of Lady
holding's judgment in December but
you're absolutely right that is one of
that has created part of the conflict
and that again will be laid out in the
statement of reasons I'd say that to The
Honorable lady what we would like the
Scottish government to do is to address
the uh concerns we have around
sufficient protections and safeguards
for women and children across uk-wide
legislation and that to be reflected in
the building
[Music]
thank you thank you Mrs Deputy speaker
could I welcome the order of the
Secretary of State made today I'm sure
the legislation passed by holyrood was
well intentioned but in their own
willingness and I don't know whether it
was stubbornness or naivety to accept
that there will be a tiny minority of
Bad actors passing that bill without the
Amendments that were proposed by my my
honorable friend here and his colleagues
means that they're putting the uh we the
text-based rights of women and girls
across the United Kingdom have at risk
and is that not the point secretary of
state that it's not just affecting
Scotland it's affecting women and girls
across the United Kingdom
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Mr Deputy speaker the real
truth of the gra discussion is that
almost five years ago this government
opened up a consultation for gra reform
and did sweet nothing on it opened up
that pandira's box of fear and of hate
and of misinformation and then one one
part of our country takes action which
we all should have taken action they
want to use it for a constructed
constitutional crisis is it not time
that this government bring forward
proper gra reform that includes the
basis that are laid out in the Scotland
act and put to bed once and for all the
lie that this is about equalities
yeah
well I I'm here to uh answer to the
Constitutional decision I've taken but
but I suggest you go to orals and ask
those questions of the minister for
women inequalities Rachel McLean
Deputy speaker in response to some of
the comments from uh the SMP benches I'm
happy to look at myself and stand up
here and speak about protections for 16
and 17 year olds who are able to self ID
as a legal opposite sex travel to this
country and then become part of our
society there is a clear read across to
the equalities act in our country having
served in the home office and seen a
desperate need for women a girl to be
protected from grooming gangs from
predators from sex offenders to access
those single sex-based Services
protection for them to do here or or
order let's not have that
you may not agree with what people are
saying but please have the respect that
they have the ability to say what they
want to say this is what we should be
doing in this house wait on the claim
so Deputy speaker does the Secretary of
State therefore agree with me this is
absolutely the right thing to do I
support his action and women and girls
across the country in the other three
nations are also going to thank him for
it yeah but I thank my honorable friend
and it is absolutely about safeguards
and protecting safe spaces for women and
children she's absolutely right in that
and the risk of lowering the bar for bad
faith actors she makes that point as
well Amy Callahan
yeah
thank you Mr Deputy speaker in acting
section 35 is disgraceful and
unprecedented and doing so brings the
risk of this political tactic being used
again does he Envision section 35 being
used against any other bills progressing
through Hollywood and if not why only
this bill
um well I say to The Honorable lady that
it she's actually right this is
unprecedented
it is a very high bar it was not a
decision I reached easily or took
lightly but I the legal advice was very
strong and it was for Section 35 and I
have used it but as I said earlier 347
acts have gone through the Scottish
Parliament so in the last nearly 24
years it the system works the Scotland
act 1998 works but in that act whether
you like it or not but whether it's SNP
like it or not however remember they did
vote for it in 1998 there is a section
35 order and it's for this type of event
Caroline Johnson
yeah there's a deputy speaker there will
be those in this house the degree and
those that disagree with the substance
of Scotland's gender recognition Reform
Bill
you as they Rush this legislation
through Hollywood
[Music]
because the UK Parliament legislation
and with the Devolution agreement inside
indeed some may speculate that that was
their intention does my right on the
phone agree with me that the SMP should
respect the Devolution agreement that
they voted for and not use women girls
or transgender individuals as Pawns in
their separatist agenda
yeah so this uh I'd say to my honorable
friend this is entirely a legal debate
we're having it's a constitution it's
about the Scotland act 1998 and we
shouldn't be bringing in or politicizing
the the transgender Community who we you
know I was disappointed by the first
Minister's remarks yesterday we we
respect them we value them this is
entirely this decision is entirely about
the legal advice I've received in
Blackford
Mr Deputy speaker we often hear about
respecting the Scottish Parliament but
isn't it the case that this absolutely
demonstrates that power devolved is
poverted we accept that the secretary of
state has the powers enshrined in the
Scotland act under Section 35 but what
the secretary of state has just done is
ignored the fact that parties that voted
for this in the Scottish Parliament had
a manifestal commitment it has the
majority support of the Scottish
Parliament and it absolutely
demonstrates to everybody in Scotland
that if you want to protect your
Parliament if you want to protect the
rights of the Scottish Parliament to
legislate and evolve matters then we
have to take away the threat of action
from the Secretary of State and the only
way the only way Mr Deputy speaker that
we protect our Parliament is by Scotland
becoming independent
Mr Speaker I've just won a 10 pound note
[Music]
[Applause]
to me
um this latest debacle from the SMP
proves that they are not fit to govern
in Scotland it's absolutely pathetic but
just the Secretary of State agree with
me let this gender Reform Bill so-called
gender Reform Bill from the SMP is just
a pathetic snidy attempt to use young
people a cynical attempt on their
pathetic Pathway to Independence
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the position I accept is that
what what I'm doing here is addressing
the legal issues as advice to my legal
counsel this is this is the issue here
is adverse effects on uk-wide
legislation the equalities act the
gender recognition recognition act 2004
and that is what I'm entirely focused on
Ben Bradshaw
Mr Deputy speaker I listen very
carefully to what the Secretary of State
said but I didn't hear a clear
explanation as to why the government
believes the Scottish gender recognition
act conflicts with the UK equality act
as in all it does is it simplifies and
demedicalizes the process of transition
it doesn't change the status of somebody
who has transitioned that used to be
conservative party policy it's the
policy of many other civilized countries
a growing number of countries it's not
good enough him to say he's going to
publish something later today he speaks
he speaks for the government he needs to
be able to explain the rationale for
this drastic move here to the house now
the government also needs to explain
what's it going to do with all those
foreign Nationals who come from
countries that already have some form of
self-identification is the government
the UK government seriously going to
take away their rights retrospectively
well no we're not and the the minister
for women equalities has done a WMS on
that and regarding the changes there are
changes which are 16 to 18 year olds uh
self ID without any medical diagnosis
these are changes but most importantly
from the legal advice I have and it will
be the same two reasons it's very
detailed which is why I don't want to
bore everyone to death with it now the
similar reason shows the adverse effects
on two pieces of uk-wide legislation and
that is the reason the section 35 is
deemed appropriate mark jenkinson thank
you Mr Deputy speaker and can I thank my
right honorable friend for standing firm
on the facts against the noise does he
agree with me that rather than
manufacturing constitutional battles the
SNP would be better focused on their
energies on fixing the failures across
Scotland not least in health and
education
well again I don't want to bore everyone
with a long list but we could add
ferries and many other things to that
list
Murray black
thank you master David speaker
um I noticed that the Secretary of State
fails to mention that this is the most
consulted piece of legislation that has
ever gone through the Scottish
Parliament so this idea that is being
rushed is nothing more than a lie now as
I've said this is already an attack on
Devolution it is an attack using and
weaponizing the most vulnerable group in
our society and on that note I want to
ask the Secretary of State then just in
his own words what does he think the
point of the Scottish Parliament is
well well the point of this culture's
Parliament is to is to serve the people
of Scotland on the areas that are
devolved to them and and but but but to
be clear within the within the Scotland
Act and the terms of the Scotland act
and it's not an attack on Devolution to
use a section 35 order where it's deemed
appropriate by legal counsel in it it
when the Scottish when the Scottish
national party voted for that very act
themselves with that that order in it
Jonathan you Mr Deputy speaker I warmly
welcome the statement made by the
Secretary of State and I once also
placed on record my support for the
heroines such as JK Rowling and others
who stand up despite the continued
aggression and violence abuse they
receive from certain people in this
place and across the Scottish Parliament
does the Secretary of State agree with
me this is simply about protecting young
girls and women to their right to having
safety in Single Sex spaces and this
politicization of that is an absolute
abomination
well it is Mr Mr Deputy speaker it's
also about protecting the Devolution
settlement and two uk-wide Acts
awesome though
Deputy speaker I've been contacted by
McKenzie and inspirational women I met
recently in my constituency and she says
I did not choose to be trans I did not
choose to have my rights taken away and
I certainly did not choose to have my
life Up For Debate from people who don't
even know or emphasize with my community
so who can he tell me in the absence of
the UK doing anything whatsoever about
improving child's rights why he's
standing in the way of the Scottish
government making progress
well I would suggest The Honorable lady
we I mean first of all of course we
respect and support Trends the trans
community and but but if she wants to
raise specific issues the minister for
women inequalities is very happy to have
a meeting with you right here well
Bristow
Mr Deputy speaker does my right
honorable friend agree that if this
house passed legislation that impinged
on what should be a devolved confidence
there would be cows or protests opposite
the facts the fact they're shouting down
women in this house over uk-based
equality legislation show that this is
not about equalities at all it's all
about bashing the UK and for them single
sex-based rights is just collateral
damage
well I that my honorable friend makes a
a very fair point this is not for me
about anything other than following the
legal advice the adverse effects and UK
wide Accords his legislation which of
course involves safe single-sex spaces
Hillary Ben thank you very much indeed
uh Mr Deputy speaker that clearly as
we've heard is disagreement about the
process that is contained within the
legislation the Scottish Parliament has
passed
but could these Secretary of State
clarify something
because whether one agrees with that or
not the net result would be someone
would be issued with a gender
recognition certificate
he argues in invoking section 35 that
this would have serious adverse impacts
on the operation of the equality act can
he explain why the same certificate
issued under the 2004 act does not have
those adverse impacts
[Applause]
exactly what what I say to The Honorable
gentle what we're trying to do here is
avoid two different regimes which
conflict either side of the Border
Nick Fletcher
speaker stand in full support the
Secretary of State's decision this
morning does my honorable friend agree
with me that the SNP are using this
subject to deliberately cause division
to further their single issue campaign
of creating an independent Scotland
regardless regardless of the
consequences to children and women
across this nation
[Applause]
um well Mr Speaker that can that's the
conclusion that some people might have
reached when listening to the question
from The Honorable member from Ross Sky
look Albert Stevens
Deputy speaker of course members
opposite and Princeton David a devolved
competencies and legislation last night
when they voted for their anti-strike
legislation become the secretary of
state tellers
since this guy's Parliament has passed
uh there's gender a recognition Reform
Bill and his decision today what
correspondences he had with the Scottish
government to try and resolve the issue
or is it him it's a bad faith actor
well as I think I've said Mr Deputy the
uh Minister for women inequalities and
officials
Civil Service officials had a number of
uh engagements my involvement comes
after the event because it is a
constitutional involvement but on the
policy area it was the gender policy
area is absolutely for the minister to
have that engagement and she not only
wrote she also had a meeting
Deputy speaker can I very warmly welcome
my right honorable friend statement
today and did he agree with me that it
does seem quite
it does seem quite extraordinary the
criticism of his decision today seems to
be that members opposite would have him
not act upon legal advice which states
that this legislation impinges upon the
rights of women children and some of the
most vulnerable in our community if the
Scottish secretary was not undertaking
this action today that would be a bigger
outrage in what we have heard here today
this government is the defender of the
rights of those who are most vulnerable
and who need protecting our society and
it is a disgrace that this has been
painted in the Constitutional light it
is by the SMP for their own end rather
than the rights of women and children in
our country
foreign
to this house and trample all over trans
rights over Scottish democracy and over
equality issued at the very least do his
homework because he clearly knows as
little about this bill as he does about
Devolution so can the Secretary of State
tell me are he and his government so
scared of democracy and equality that he
really thinks it's justifiable to use
one of the most marginalized groups in
our society as political fodder in their
anti-trans anti-equality and
anti-democratic endeavors
well Mr Deputy speaker I don't recognize
any of those remarks this is this is
absolutely following legal advice and
not taking the decision lightly on the
adverse effects that this bill has on
two uh UK y g b wide bills and that is
the position we're in we have written to
the Scottish government to explain our
position we will lay the statement of
reasons later this is nothing to do with
trampling over transgender rights this
is entirely to do with following a legal
process and taking the legal advice that
we sought
much Mr Deputy speaker the Secretary of
State for Scotland knows the value in
which I hold the union so I'm sure he
will understand how difficult this is
for me but as a Scottish woman the
mother of a Scottish daughter someone
who has campaigned and continues to
campaign and work for women's safety I
have heard the concerns
and I have looked at every clause and
amendment of this bill
spoken with MSP colleagues from all
parties in the search for where it
undermines the equalities Act and the
protections and Single Sex species and
others that it offers me
and every other woman that I know I
can't find it exactly some of the UK's
finest legal Minds have poured over this
hugely scrutinized bill in great detail
and found no conflict but I can see
where it actually guarantees that it
will not challenge the Primacy of the
equalities act so can the Secretary of
State point me to the exact lines of
this bill which he feels undermines my
and every other woman's rights and
justify why he is playing fast and loose
with the Union
and really
doing so much to heart the most
vulnerable people in our society
well that's simply not true I'm looking
to protect the vulnerable as she will
see and the legal opinion May well be
divided on this but the legal opinion
we've taken is that there are adverse
effects on the equalities Act and the
gender recognition
2004 act and I and and I I note the
first Minister's comments this uh
earlier today that she intends to take
this to judicial review so we'll find
out in the court of opinion the sorry
whether the court of opinion that I've
been hearing is right or wrong when we
go to the legal cause
Olivia Blake thank you Mr Deputy speaker
I would love to hear from the minister
um more detail on the legal advice that
has been given because I'm still unclear
the equality act and I would also like
to say isn't it true that the only
reason we are here is because of
government failure to listen to its own
consultation with a hundred thousand
people responding to it and also using
trans people as a political football for
example leaving them out of the
conversion therapy until conveniently
this week
well look I I would not urge the benches
object to to reflect the tone here this
is a legal decision we need to take the
heat out of this debate that we are what
we're doing what we're what we are
dealing with is a reduction in
safeguards for women and children that
is the legal advice we have and later
later when you read the statement of
reasons you will be able to draw your
own conclusions
Stuart Malcolm McDonald
I'm sure the United king Dom King's
first ever female first minister is
enjoying the lecture from the Secretary
of State and the various Cicero tribute
acts behind them on feminism and the
protection of women's rights isn't it
the case Mr Deputy speaker that what we
have here is a decaying government in
its last months in office needing some
red meat for its base an utterly supine
labor party trying to triangulate
through all of this meanwhile trans
people are the collateral damage just as
section 28 haunted Thatcher's government
section 35 will always be associated
with him so let me ask him he must
surely have the statement of reasons in
that folder on his knee read that out
from the dispatch box
yeah we we will publish the statement of
reasons and all your the other remarks
The Honorable gentleman made Mr Deputy
speaker opinions may vary
with several Roberts
this is a calculated attack on
Devolution
democracy and trans rights and it's
increasingly clear
that this tired and bitter Tory
government will weaponize any issue no
matter how sensitive and they'll do that
to subvert evolution
now this is really about the equality
Act ministers will be referring this to
the courts
they wouldn't be withholding their own
legal advice they would be seen to have
this tested in the courts rather than
taking as they are unprecedented
unilateral action
so what does he have to say
to the unionist Welsh labor Minister
Vaughn guessing who today said that this
UK government undermines the Union
yeah
yeah yeah well well obviously I entirely
agree with we are supporting the union
the the Devolution bill is being is is
what we believe in and section 35 order
was democratically put there and we
believe that we have to take the legal
advice we have and people say read out
the statement of reason the statement of
reasons and and my order will be have
been submitted to parliamentary
authorities and they'll be available in
the time frame when they decide to
release them this afternoon and you will
be able to read everything you want to
read there as the reasons behind this
but essentially it's about protecting
and safeguarding women and children
where we believe there are adverse
effects thirsty Blackman
of rising hate crime my trans siblings
will be horrified and terrified at the
level of misinformation and lies in this
chamber today given that the secretary
of state has had lots of legal advice on
this presumably he's also had briefings
on this cootie Talos what is the effect
of a gender recognition certificate what
does it entitle someone to do
yeah yeah well well we we believe with
the with the the we believe you'll see
in the legals in the in the same two
reasons that there is a reduction I made
this very Point very clear there is a
reduction in safeguards for women and
children and and you will have plenty of
time to read that today
daddy with him
here Mr Zachary speaker
the reason why the government can't tell
us exactly what the conflict is with the
equality Act is because there isn't one
the Scottish gender recognition Reform
Bill does not affect the operation of
the equality act and everyone in this
house knows that full well because labor
MSP Pam Duncan glancy put it on the face
of the bill with with their Amendment so
will the admit will the minister admit
what this section 35 order is really
about and that is Fanning the Flames of
a culture war that is harming trans
people across the UK
no Mr Speaker that's an appalling thing
to say it is it is entirely it is
entirely addressing the legal advice
that I've been given and the legal
advice tells me that there is a
reduction in safeguards across
conflicting with two uk-wide bills and
that is the reason for the section 35
order and that is why the advice was to
use it and it will be available to all
this afternoon
did you Brock Deputy speaker and has it
been as has been clarified by my
honorable friend the member for
the South
six years now if the UK government
thought there was some legal basis to
challenge the bill why didn't they do so
in the Supreme Court through a section
33 order before now as they've done
previously
I'm afraid I don't want I don't want to
be rude to The Honorable lady but um I'm
afraid what she just said shows that she
does not understand the Scotland act or
whatever what actions are available to
the United Kingdom government we cannot
bring forward a section 33 act while a
bill is going through uh the Scottish
Parliament nor can we invoke a section
35 act while the bill is going through
once the bill is finished its final
stage it's third stage there's a 28-day
process and the legal advice which we I
must say This legal advice is taken on
all bills that the Scottish Parliament
passes that's part of the Devolution
settlement and then we and then we
decide then we decide what course needs
to be taken based on the advice we get
and on this occasion the advice is that
the section 33 is not appropriate but a
section 35 is
[Music]
Owen Thompson
I have to say it's exceptionally
discovered
is to the statement of reasons that
nobody in here except him appears to be
able to be seen this isn't an urgent
question this wasn't something that he
didn't know about this was a statement
that he brought himself so we should
have had the statement of reasons before
if we came to this statement but I
wanted to ask the Secretary of State
what is it about persistent electoral
failure in Scotland that makes him so
averse to following the principles of
basic democracy
[Applause]
Mr Deputy speaker this is beyond parody
it's democracy democracy is what the
Scotland Act is section 35 is in the
Scotland act the SNP voted for the
Scotland act with Section 35 in it it is
a democratic instrument Jim Shannon you
must have this speaker can I thank the
minister of for a statement uh and agree
that women and girls must be protected
and safeguarded the minister will be
aware that a precedent was set for the
circumnavigation of the evolution When
government here brought abortion and
demand legislation for Northern Ireland
with great respect to my colleagues in
this family I recall the members who are
my friends representing Scotland uh
I do not recall the members defending
the cause then for Northern Ireland so
will the minister confirm the president
supported by many who are opposing today
means that the government retains a
right to step in for issues that they
deem to be equality on human rights
well I'm not an expert in on the
Northern Ireland bills so I won't I
won't stray into that area but I will
say that that the the the protections
and safeguards for women and children
that we have been advised need to be
looked at by these adverse effects
that's what we're dealing with with
Section 35 act today which is part of
the Scotland act okay Dugan thank you Mr
Speaker you would think that before
pulling the trigger on a section 35
you'd be absolutely across your brief
but it seems to do that the Secretary of
State hasn't got a clue about this at
all we've had very little about process
and even less about substance but the
secretary of state says that this would
have significant impact on amongst other
things GB wide equality matters in
Scotland England and Wales what
consultation can I ask then has he had
with the Welsh government or Senate
before this drastic intervention or is
this really an issue for the de facto
English government as a priority and
isn't it the case that with Independence
looming larger than ever before this
crumbling Union this is an act of
death's desperate Democratic vandalism
no and I I believe the Scottish the the
UK government did consult a number of
you who get the minister for women
equalities tells me did consult a number
of years ago and Wales would have been
included in that would have been
included in that consultation but the
the point is that there is no Democratic
whatever that you're saying it's
entirely a democratic bill that uh has
section 35 in it that we are now using
that order to protect what we believe uh
is of women and children's safeguards
because we believe they are undermined
by the cutter cross into two GB wide
bills
Wayne David
speaker
in his response to the Shadow the
Secretary of State the Secretary of
State for Scotland said but article 35
in the 1998 Act was not an instrument of
Last Resort
but then after that there was the
memorandum of understanding sent in 2012
which made it an instrument of last
result by Common agreement so I want to
ask the Secretary of State what
discussions on a constitutional basis
has he had with the first minister of
Scotland to avoid this impasse
yeah well I'm glad I I thank the uh
honorable Judge for that point because
it it's not the last it's not the last
resort what I said to his honorable
friend what I said to his honorable
friend is that is that we have 28 days
we take the legal advice we have to act
within that 28 days uh because then
failing that the bill goes for Royal
ascent and that's the time frame we
operate in there are then there's then
the opportunity for further discussions
with the Scottish government to uh see
if we can get the legislation in scope
we made the same offer with the uncrc
bill which we took to a section 33 and
that uh offer still stands
we we we're happy to discuss with the
Scottish government what amendments
could be made to the bill to get it in
scope and not cut across UK have adverse
effects in UK wide legislation so you
know the last resort isn't Last there's
never quite a last resort when you can
go on talking talking and discussing and
trying to resolve your differences
Stuart Hosey the deputy speaker it's
true that UK ministers do have the right
to interfere under Section 35 in
Scottish legislation on the grounds of
Defense National Security International
obligations or if the Scottish
legislation modifies or has an adverse
effect on UK reserved law that much is
clear but given the Tory chair of the
women and the qualities committee has
said that the grr legislation quotes
does not change the equalities act and
that the Scottish secretary has been
singularly incapable of giving a single
example of where it might this is not
about process this is a debate on
principle and would it not be better
would it not be better instead of
interfering instead of engaging in a
rather crass culture War if the Scottish
secretary apologized to trans people
apology advertise for trampling over
Scottish democracy folded up his little
red folder and removed the threat to
interfere yeah
well I I asked again let's just take the
heat out of this debate this is this is
about the the 2010 equalities act which
is a a GB wide piece of legislation and
the legal advice we have that there are
adverse effects to that bill that's
entirely what it is and that will be
published this afternoon in the
statement of reasons
Stephen Farrell thank you Mr Speaker I
stand on solidarity with Scottish
colleagues across the political Spectrum
it is worth pointing right that it's
important that we do harmonize the cold
in rights issues upwards but the UK is
not at the University in these matters
the secretary said let's jump backwards
and forwards in terms of describing the
equality act as either uk-wide or Great
Britain it does not apply in North
Island just to make that very clear in
terms of the record but in particular
those assembly said recognize that
similar legislation has been in place in
the Republic of Ireland for over seven
years now and we in the UK have the
common travel area with Ireland which
has reciprocal rights of freedom of
movements and also in terms of Social
Security and other areas so if the
government can manage to live with a
different system of GRA in Ireland why
not Scotland
[Applause]
well well last time I looked the
Republic of Ireland wasn't part of Great
Britain all the United Kingdom it is
quite it is is absolutely the case that
we're talking about British citizens
here being affected the I I'm told there
is no there is no devolved
Administration anywhere in Europe that
has different gender rules to the state
Oswald
oh sorry Mr speaker thank you
um it's really very regrettable that the
secretary of state has come here today
on this issue and with so little
information I think that all of those
this very vulnerable group are impacted
by what He is wanting to do really
deserves significantly better than the
Secretary of State standing up
repeatedly with absolutely no
information telling us that a statement
of reasons will be published later and
yet he is unable to tell us what these
reasons are it is his job to tell us
what these reasons are and he has
singularly failed to do that today it is
no wonder that his former colleague the
former British conservative heads of
communications Andy McKeever when
looking at how the UK government is
dealing with this issue has described
the UK government intervening here as an
act of constitutional vandalism and he
said it demonstrates westminster's
superiority complex in overdrive does
the Secretary of State recognize that
people will reasonably and rightly feel
that way and that as well as their
concerns about this marginalized group
they will feel extremely unhappy about
this overriding of our democracy
well and Mr deaf speaker no I I hope
people realize that the United Kingdom
government has been given legal advice
that raises concerns for women and
children and their safeguards and
protections and and adverse effects to
uk-wide legislation and the and that we
are acting on that and we have the we
have the backs of women and children
across the United Kingdom and in
Scotland if the if they are safeguards
and their Single Sex spaces only and and
Etc are impinged upon if that's the
issue that if that is the issue that you
will see in the statement of reasons if
that's the concern we believe it is
right to act on that for all citizens of
Great Britain
Mr Speaker the one in the qualities
Committee in 21 published a report which
clearly stated then and is still the
case now that the gender recognition
certificate did not impinge on women or
girls rights it was very clear and very
unequivocal it stated very clearly that
the exclusions applied in all instances
and that women and girls would continue
to be protected regardless of the gender
recognition certificate the same applies
in this case the gender recognition
format and there is nothing within the
proposals that contradicts that so will
the minister stand here today now
clearly an issue very outline of what
liquidity has been given in state here
in this chamber right now what the legal
advice is because we're still waiting
Mr Deputy speaker in short two different
regimes create adverse effects see
McDonald's yeah Mr Speaker these answers
are absolutely pathetic can I ask why is
it that states and territories in the
U.S and Canada and Australia can
successfully operate self ID without
interference or complaint from either
neighboring territories or from central
government but that can't happen here we
were supposed to have the most a
powerful evolved parliament in the world
and secondly can I ask him why does the
equalities unit fact cheat but just by
his government for its own consultation
and self ID State clearly there will be
no change to the provision of women-only
spaces and services this has been a law
since 2010 and will not change he's
grabbing around for legal advice in
order to Peddle myths in this chamber is
he not
foreign
Administration in Europe that had
different uh had different gender rules
to the state and but the honorable
gentleman raises the USA Canada and
Australia where there's no Central ID
law because they're very differently
they are federal structures
if the state maybe take some heat out of
this argument by confirming a few
matters of fact that a lot of his
colleagues seem to be unaware of could
you confirm that this harsh piece of
legislation has been under six years of
scrutiny by the Scottish Parliament
could they confirm that during that
period in the last Scottish Parliament
elections an overfelding majority of
msps were elected on explicit Manifesto
commitments in favor of this legislation
could it confirm that there's absolutely
nothing in this legislation that makes
any difference to the rights or ability
of anybody to go into any protected
Single Sex base in Scotland or anywhere
else in the world and finally will I
confirmed that Fanny final eventually
has occur to say so let us see what he
intends to put forward an advice in
which it is based will he guarantee that
this house will have a further chance to
consider and vote on what he's proposing
well um I didn't catch all of everything
as my tinnitus gets the better of me
sometimes and I didn't catch everything
The Honorable gentleman said but I think
he uh I think he he asked if I mean as
to all the legal reasons we've covered
that 100 times today but as to whether
or not there'll be a chance for another
debate and another vote my understanding
was section 35 is that the opposition
had 40 days to Prey Upon it and that
would then lead to a debate in this
Parliament Patrick Greg thank you Mr
Speaker I think the Secretary of State
for vetoing Scotland is going to be
quite disappointed when he eventually
gets to the House of Lords because not
even for all its faults does the House
of Lords have the kind of veto power
that he's exercising today indeed even
the United States president if he vetoes
a bill is subject to checks and balances
by the Congress so just further to my
friend and further to what he just said
if a motion is tabled praying against
the section 35 order will the government
guarantee that time will be made
available for a debate and a vote on the
floor of this house
well that Mr Mr Speaker is a question
for the leader of the House
thank you Mr Speaker and good afternoon
he said it is open to the Scottish
government to bring back an amended bill
for reconsideration in the Scottish
Parliament can I ask what Provisions
would need to be added or taken away
from the original bill to make it
acceptable to this government
uh yeah yes Mr Speaker I think I said
earlier that
the basically regarding the amendment
any Amendment to the bill if the
Scottish government want to bring it
back they have to address I know there
are difficulties for them this but they
would have to address the diff the the
central issue which is that the so we
don't believe in in the cross cut
against GB legislation that there are
sufficient protections and safeguards
for women and children and there is as I
say it's been it is as reflected in
existing Westminster legislation
I want to get through to this after the
10 minute rule build I will take points
water before depending on what the house
decides I call Stephen Flynn to make an
application to leave to propose a debate
on the Pacific and important matter that
should Divergent consideration under the
terms of standing order number 24 The
Honorable member has three minutes in
which to make such an application
so yeah thank you very much Mr Speaker
and I Rise to seek your permission to
have a debate this afternoon under
section 24 of standing orders in respect
of the unprecedented and unjustifiable
decision of this United Kingdom
government to overturn the views and the
legislative program of the
democratically elected members of
Scotland's national parliament in
Hollywood the Mr Speaker the arguments
on this matter are lengthy some of them
have just been covered many more will
hopefully be covered in a debate to come
should you so seek to Grant it and I am
not seeking to be presumptuous in that
regard but should you seek to Grant it I
will endeavor to cover those many points
and to highlight to this chamber and to
the public the Democratic shortfall that
exists at the heart of the supposed
Union of equals thank you Mr Speaker
the role member has to leave to propose
a debate on specific and important
matter this Divergent consideration
namely that this house is considered the
government's decision to use section 35
of the Scotland act with regard to the
gender recognition reform Scotland bill
I have listened carefully to the
application of General member I am
satisfied that the matter raised by the
oral member is proposal to be discussed
understanding order number 24 and that
the honorable member has leave of the
house
is no objection
with
we then come to the motion the remember
has obtained the leave of the house the
debate will be held today immediately
after the 10-minute rule motion the
debate will last two hours and will
arise on the motion that the house has
consider that the specific matter set
out in the honorable members application
I should remind the house and the
standing order number 24 provides for
additional time taken by this debate to
be added on the end of the proceedings
of the safety bill right let us know
Bill to the 10-minute rule
I said I was going to deal with them
after 10 minutes I'm going to put them
all together
okay we now come to the tenant rule
build
Simon Bank
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I beg to move that leave be
given to bring in a bill to require the
Secretary of State to undertake a review
of the support available to markets and
Market Traders and of the options for
improving that support and for connected
purposes markets Mr Speaker are close to
my heart as my grandfather's butcher's
business R.A Dodds was based in the
Granger Market in Newcastle where they
had five stalls and from where they
expanded between the walls to establish
shops across Northumberland I grew up
hearing stories of the family business
which sadly no longer exists but the
memories are still strong as I found a
few years ago when visiting Granger
Market also when I was mayor of Clan
Laughlin five years ago I played a key
part in establishing a farmer's market
in the town each summer
I am delighted to have 11 colleagues
from across the house as co-sponsors of
this bill and I know they like me
strongly support their local markets
particularly my constituency neighbor
The Honorable member for wrexham with
whom I as the MP for fluid South share
the Parliamentary representation of
wrexham County Borough Council the city
of wrexham has its Origins as a market
town and the livestock market was at one
time the largest in Wales The People's
Market is now teapot the Central Market
continues in its traditional way and the
butcher's Market is due for
redevelopment next year to offer a wide
range of high quality Welsh food and
drink markets also play an important
role in fluid South where Street and
specialist markets held in clangothlin
on the Riga State and elsewhere in the
constituency make a marked contribution
to our society
I was also until August last year the
chair of the all-party Parliamentary
markets Group which gave me further
valuable Insight in this into the
successes and needs of the markets
industry
markets are part of the history and
tradition of many towns and cities in
the UK the most recent survey of the
markets industry indicates some
1150 traditional markets are now trading
at our outlet for an amazing figure of
over 32 000 small and medium-sized
Enterprises they exist through Charters
from the crown custom and practice and
statutory legislation in addition there
are numerous specialist markets
continental and Christmas markets that
generate essential footfall for Town and
City centers and support local economies
tourism hospitality and employment
two national organizations represent the
markets industry the association of
British Market authorities magma that
focuses on Market operators local
authorities private operators CICS and
Charities and the national markets
Traders Federation nmtf that supports
Market Traders across the UK both
organizations currently meet with the
government through the retail forum and
the all-party Parliamentary markets
group
slowly the market industry is returning
from the financial community and
personal damages of covid the recovery
has seen some markets enjoying success
in attracting investment as part of
exciting regeneration schemes but for
others the picture is still not
encouraging the nagma 2022 survey was
the first meaningful assessment of the
state of the markets industry since the
pandemic the main headlines and
questions arising from a survey of 241
markets are as follows store occupancy
has fallen from a national average of 77
four years ago to 72 percent Street
Markets and outdoor covered markets have
seen the greatest decline how can we
reverse the decline more markets are
operating that they are operating at a
loss a six percent increase from four
years ago only 40 percent of markets are
trading with a surplus is this
sustainable going forward and how can
this be reversed markets feature heavily
as part of town and City regeneration
for a number of local authorities how
can government funding be attracted to
deliver successful and modern markets
traditional family businesses are
declining especially those specialist
business such as butchers and
fishmongers how does the market industry
attract new and younger Traders
markets are at the heart of local
communities they are part of local
history but also have a role a key role
to play in the future of communities and
government initiatives particularly
leveling up
a key area for the government to address
is on business rates in 2022 business
rates assessed on markets totals over 20
million pounds the chancellor announce
the relief of business rates for many
businesses but due to an anomaly local
Authority markets do not enjoy the
benefits of this measure now because of
restrictions in the local Authority
Finance legislation a local Authority
cannot Grant a concession to itself on
business rates whereas private markets
can take advantage of the benefits
therefore a key part of the review
called for in this bill would be for the
government to look at extending business
rate relief to local Authority markets
including Parish town and Community
councils Markets operated under
charitable trust should also be
beneficiaries the markets industry has
taken several important initiatives via
namma and nmtf to address areas which
need more support I believe that these
initiatives provide pointers to the
areas in which the government could
focus its support for the industry
firstly recognizing the fall in Market
occupancy in local businesses the
industry is delivering a campaign
entitled grow a business in 2023 to
attract more individuals to try out
market trading this is especially for
young Traders but also individuals that
are looking at a second or new career
part of the historic success of market
trading is to see small businesses
prosper and grow and then move into the
local High Street never has this been
more important secondly the industry's
young Traders Market campaign celebrated
its 10th anniversary in 2022 from
relatively Small Beginnings it has grown
into an incredibly successful campaign
the windows go on to 10 Regional finals
involving 250 young people and then 90
of them go to the National final held in
stratford-uponaven during the campaign
many sustainable businesses have been
created and it is a flagship for the
industry thirdly the love your local
market campaign has got on from strength
to strength over the last 12 years its
origin lay in the Mary portus review and
the future of the high streets which was
commissioned by former Prime Minister
David Cameron in 2011.
the government at the time was concerned
with the same issues as concerned the
government today the contraction of
retail and it would see seeking to
deliver real change in communities and
make towns multifunctional places to
live work and visit markets featured
prominently in the Porter's report which
said markets can serve as fundamental
traffic drivers back to our high streets
they love your local market Campaign
which is now in its 12th year attracts
more and more support and is now
celebrated around the world in over 25
countries
government provided funding support to
launch The Campaign which serves as an
important Catalyst to change
in conclusion Mr Deputy speaker the
value of markets to our local
communities is widely recognized and I
know that the government is Keen to be
as supportive as possible
as is called for in this bill a review
by the government of the support
available for markets and of the options
for improving that support will be
welcomed with open arms by market
operators and Traders alike and bring
lasting benefits to our communities
across the length and breadth of the UK
hey
this would normally be the opportunity
for one MP who wishes to oppose
this 10-minute rule motion to do so I
see nobody wishes to do so and I have
had no indication either so I'll just
pose the question and the question is
that honorable member have leave to
bring in the bill as many of that
opinions say aye
of the country no I think the eyes have
it the eyes have it who will prepare and
bring in the bill
Sarah Atherton Paul Bristow James Daly
Sally Earnhardt Mr David Jones Ben Lake
Robin Miller Robbie Moore Helen Morgan
Jim Shannon Matt Vickers and myself Mr
Deputy speaker Baines
[Applause]
thank you markets and Market Traders
review of support Bill second reading
what day Friday the 24th of February is
the Deputy speaker Friday the 24th of
February thank you very much
please
Emma
thank you Mr Speaker I'm very grateful
for you taking a a point of order and at
the earlier um program in the house you
rightly agreed for a section 24
emergency application which the house
has agreed to hold today but I fear we
may have a bit of an empty debate
because the statement of reasons for why
the government have called the section
35 order which is unprecedented has
never happened in the history of this
house before have not been given to
members and will not be led until later
this afternoon in the library and I
wonder if it could seek your guidance of
whether or not the section 24 debate
should be postponed until such times as
not only have they been published but
we've had time to digest them can I just
say we have got the secretary of state
with us I thought that we'd like to
inform the house we were up to
so State thank you Mr Speaker
um so the the we laid the order at 12 34
with the statement of reasons the house
authorities have to clear it before they
publish it they won't do that till 5 PM
however what I have got dispensation to
do from from Mr Speaker I don't know
I've got dispensation to publish it on
the UK gov website the statement of
reasons we're doing that now they're
being emailed to you to um The Honorable
member for Edinburgh West and to The
Honorable member for Aberdeen South you
are having them emailed the statement of
reasons email to you now
thank you Mr Speaker in relation to what
the Secretary of State for Scotland has
just said uh we're about to or we've had
uh in excess of an hour's worth of
questioning to him where he's repeatedly
mentioned the statement of reasons which
we have until this point not seen I'm
now being told that I'm going to receive
this statement of reasons I think it
would be wise Mr Speaker with your
guidance for the house to be suspended
so that all of us can consider those
reasons and feel prior to the debate
because they will have obviously an
intrinsic value to all of us in that
regard yeah
Mr Speaker
sorry further start point forward and
then I will come
oh cool yes cool now hey thank you Mr
Speaker it remains all right I mean to
be convinced whether or not the
Secretary of State understands the
effect of our gender recondition
certificate but it is surely now
apparent that he does not understand the
concept of parliamentary accountability
as long as I have been in this house if
the house were to be amid aware of a
government document or a publication of
any sort that was placed in the house of
problems Library it was not sent by
email to individual named members surely
all members of this United Kingdom
Parliament have an interest in knowing
what the government position is and
there is no good reason for this
unprecedented departure from previous
process
Mr Speaker and this has been an
absolutely
the secretary state with a voluntary
statement he wasn't forced to the house
if they're an urgent person he came
forward
and essential to the government's case
has been that the grr bill is passed by
the Scottish Parliament conflicts with
the equality act it is a statement of
reasons as to why that is the case he
never provided that statement for the of
reasons for that for members to question
about now he's going to be supplying it
through email could I insist that you
follow the original Scottish national
party system we have an opportunity to
jump to consider this properly that we
could come back and question the
secretary who has to be in the dispatch
box in the next debate on these
statements of the reasons we get to
question on the reasons why this UK
government has invoking a section 35
order against this legislation
very much Mr Speaker and I noticed that
the Secretary of State in the previous
session it said that he had not brought
the statement of reasons and that he did
not want to bore us with it and I found
that quite an extraordinary statement
given the gravity of the situation and
the gravity of the subject's matter that
we are dealing with I wonder if he has
now changed his mind and doesn't think
that it is something that is hideous and
boring for us to deal with but actually
realizes that this is a serious
important uh piece of dialogue that we
should have had from him in advance of
this session and I wonder if you're able
to give us any guidance Mr Speaker on
how everyone who wanted to contribute to
the previous session and didn't have the
information might be able to contribute
to this session in full possession of
the information yeah
thank you Mr Speaker I wonder if you can
advise the house if this situation has
any precedent where a government
minister or Secretary of State can turn
up at the dispatch box without the
necessary accompanying information to
advise and guide the discussion and
debate in a in a question session which
which it seems the different in my
experience here since I was elected Mr
Speaker seems to be the way that things
are supposed to have been done is this
precedented or is this unprecedented
this shambolic behavior from the
Secretary of State for Scotland
right well I think we've got to try and
make some Pro sorry Owen Thompson I know
thank you Mr Speaker and I appreciate
that I see your advice and I apologize
to Mr Deputy speaking of trying to
intervene during the the question
session however I think it's important
because the statement of reasons is
clearly a critical factor and the
discussion we're having we've not been
able to question the secretary say on
through the statement he made I'll tell
you when he brought the statement we're
going to have a debate which is
encouraging and welcome but most of us
won't have a chance to have seen the
statement of reasons before that starts
so can I ask for your advice Mr Speaker
as to what further opportunities even
beyond the section 24 debate members of
this chamber will have to question the
secretary to say in detail on the
statement of reasons when we eventually
get around to publishing it yeah yeah
statement from a secretary of state they
kept referring to the statement of
reasons but yet wouldn't devote any
information it also kept referring to
the women that called equalities managed
up and said that she would actually be
able to answer all the questions so Mr
Speaker that at any point did the
government discuss who was the most
appropriate person to bring forward this
statement so that we could ask his
honorable members question the
government properly and ask somebody
that actually had some knowledge to be
able to answer questions all right gonna
have to make some put no no I'm gonna
come it's just slightly separate so
don't worry what I want to do is to try
and say Luke in an Ideal World yes it
will be Asia it is now live and I hope
that it should have been an email to
certain members to ensure that they can
see it don't shake your head just yet
just check if you want that Bell well no
it says we could argue that the
secretary of state has set it out for
over an hour in which he answered the
question which I got I got which
answered the question but what I want to
do is ensure that this debate goes ahead
we could have put it off to tomorrow and
quite right that you wanted it today
which is important so I'm going to go
ahead it's not the best way to start the
debate I do ask you to check I am
assured it is online and is available
for members to do but I do want to do
this next very important point of order
which I've been waiting just enjoy to
come in on this bit because I do want to
separate the two
thank you Mr Speaker I I have many
skills at my disposal but the ability to
speak whilst also looking at the
government's statement of reasons is
certainly not one of them I think it is
entirely unfair for me as an elected
member in this house to partake in a
debate which you have kindly grounded
out and granted and I appreciate that
without being in full possession of the
facts that is not my fault Mr Speaker
that is the fault of the Secretary of
State for Scotland two whilst
undermining Scotland's demolition he's
not just undermining Scotland's
Devolution Mr Speaker he's undermining
this place and that is of serious
consequence to you I imagine
okay no no I've got to answer that point
about the first I think yeah yeah well
it would say is that this isn't the end
this is the beginning there will be lots
of opportunities where this will further
be discussed but I want to make sure
this debate starts and it's important
that you do lay out the facts hopefully
during this time you will have been
started to read it what I want to do is
deal with the point of order for maybe
Callan who's quite rightly been waiting
and I wanted to separate the two issues
because I do believe it's an important
one
Mr Speaker on a point of order a secret
advice as to what options are open to
correct the record after the member for
Stoke-on-Trent North who is no longer in
his place spread misinformation in his
question that people in this house and
in Hollywood are inciting violence on
the issue of the grr
that is a matter of opinion but what I
would say and I really do recommend that
members are very careful in the language
that they use and it is important that
we show tolerance but more importantly
that we show respect to each other and
nothing should inflame the tensions that
will already be running high so I thank
the Roman member for raising that point
with me I do say to all members please
think long and hard before you speak
because messages that you say in this
house can be reflected in a way that I
do not wish to say right let us well
sorry I forgot about you Mr Christopher
Joe
so it's a relatively trivial point of
all to compare with the previous ones
but it nevertheless it relates to the
procedures in this house so you were
present in the chair during topical
questions today and you would have heard
the energy Minister seemingly criticize
me for not having given prior notice of
the topical question which I chose to
ask I I I had it I had originally in
mind to ask a different question but
because that earlier question had
already been answered I thought it would
be perfectly reasonable to choose
another topical subject and I was
disappointed that my right honorable
friend did not know the answer because
because there is a lot of evidence come
out recently that there has been a
15-fold increase in the number of
household frats in 2022 caused a buy
solar panels and I'm surprised that the
minister didn't know anything about it
the minister wants to her
in which case I land through it for you
and of course you can ask any question
that's the whole idea of job at all is
to keep the minister alive and on his
feet
it's not for me to apologize when a
minister cannot answer let's leave it at
that
is it on something
else if it's the word I've already ruled
I want to make progress
if it's completely different I'll judge
in a second please I was just wanting to
ask Mr Speaker that given that we're
going to go into this debate and haven't
seen the stuff will you give us a
measure of flexibility if we need to nip
out to get a copy and because we haven't
seen it and and then still allow us to
speak even if we miss a few seconds of
the debate I'm sure we could even bring
the copies in for you in fact I do see
that Mr Halsey is already doing having
due diligence in delivering and quite
rightly too we now come to the emergency
debate I call the leader of the s p
Stephen Flynn to move the motion
thank you thank you very much Mr
speaker here we have it
here we have it eventually and I'm
expected to read this whilst off so
speaking I have to admit Mr Speaker
there is a real Temptation for me to
stand here and read every single word of
this into the record right now
oh they want me too much stuff because
they probably shouldn't guard me too it
probably works I will I will and I'll
come back to Mr Speaker on a on a more
serious note on a more serious
on a more serious note Mr Speaker I want
to start
with an apology
an apology to those people I was and I
think this should apply to everyone I
respective of your views and respect of
the grr an apology to those people whose
hopes and whose aspirations for the
future
who fought so hard for a piece of
legislation for so long
that they now see that hope is being
taken away from them and it's being
taken away from them by a government
that they didn't vote for
but we haven't voted for since
1955. and Mr Speaker this goes to the
heart of this very issue because this
issue
eyes very core is about democracy on
these islands and what democracy looks
like on these islands within this United
Kingdom
in Scotland's democratically elected
parliament in holyroot legislation has
been passed which relates directly
directly to a devolved competency
that legislation the grr bill is the
most consulted upon legislation in the
history of the Scottish Parliament that
legislation received support not just
from the Scottish national party but
from the labor party in Scotland
conservative party members in Scotland
including the right honorable member for
Murray's predecessor as I understand it
to be the case
in a moment I received support from the
liberal Democrats in Scotland and have
received support from The Greens in
Scotland in totality it received support
from nearly two-thirds of Scotland's
democratically elected parliament in
holyroot it is an outrage Mr Speaker
that we have a situation in this United
Kingdom where this government is seeking
to overturn the Mandate and the
legislation put down by the people in
our parliament in Scotland I will I will
thank one book friend for giving
chance to
for the this appalling decision and my
my honorable friend uh spoke earlier
um about the the World Trade at the
World Health Organization and the other
European and Commonwealth Nations who
have this legislation already and how
Scotland would be brought into line with
that and uh these this statement says
removing a number of measures which the
UK government regards the important
safeguards are the very measures perhaps
if the honorable gentleman wants to pipe
down and listen he might learn something
and these measures which include the
medicalization of the process and indeed
the breach of human rights which
includes having to present a trans
person having to present themselves to a
panel just to justify their existence
are the very things that we sought to
remove because it made the rights of
trans people uh so affected I I thank my
honorable friend for that worthwhile
contribution I didn't hear all of it in
its entirety because of some of the
Rabid Gammon to my right hand side but
it was nonetheless an incredibly
important point to make and it's
actually important uh well in the
morning it's actually important to
reflect upon that because we heard
during The Question session when the
secretary of state was talking Mr
Speaker and some of the questions that
were coming from conservative back
ventures in and around me running the
debate that's actually happened already
in Hollywood we've had numerous members
on the conservative benches suggesting
that they oppose the grr for a number of
different reasons but those reasons have
already been exhausted in Scotland's
democratically elected Parliament if
members on those benches have issues
with what the Scottish Parliament has
put forward they should perhaps jump on
a train go to Scotland get themselves
elected in Scotland to the Scottish
Parliament and try to change legislative
Edition there rather than using this
place to overturn Scotland's
democratically elected problem I'll give
way to my honorable member I thank you
for governor said that the grr bill
passed with cross-party sport at Hall
Road including some conservative msps
they wanted to conservative damage msps
was Jamie green the conservatives party
spokesperson for justice now Gavin has
role he showed good courage to vote for
that but isn't it the case that his
leader don't remember for Maori has just
saw Jamie green down the river
I entirely agree and perhaps The
Honorable member from Murray would like
to address that point himself I'm
grateful to The Honorable gentleman for
giving weep and he's speaking about
people who have supported and opposed
the bill can he confirm that a Scottish
government Justice Minister resigned her
position to oppose the bill a former
Scottish government s p cabinet
secretary voted against it and in total
nine SMP msps felt this legislation was
deeply flawed was wrong and they voted
against it
Mr Speaker the member uh whilst he sits
in this chamber of course already sits
in holyrood as well and he will be
familiar with the fact that the majority
the overwhelming majority of
parliamentarians elected to Hollywood
voted in favor of this legislation now I
appreciate that he lost that debate in
Hollywood but he should not be
supportive of this government trying to
overturn that decision and that would be
really interested to hear about the
conversations that he's had with his
elected colleagues in Hollywood about
this particular decision
course and I'm grateful to The Honorable
gentleman for giving me a second time of
course I have had conversations because
I was the only party leader in Scotland
to make this a free vote to allow
members of my party to come to a
conclusion as Jamie green did Nicholas
sturgeon and the SMP refused to do that
which is why she lost government
ministers as a result
so we're going to talk about losing Mr
Speaker The Honorable gentleman lost the
debate in Scotland and I will repeat
once again it is not Democratic to try
and overturn that legislation here in
this place
I'm not going to get away no I want to
make a little bit of process cool guys
now Mr Speaker it's been it's been
unfaird by some members on the
conservative benches opposite this is in
some way in conflict with the equalities
act indeed I'm sure that within this
this tone before me that that is the
case but yet the senior members on those
benches have also been vocal about the
fact that it doesn't intervene or
overturn the equalities act in any way
shape or form so which one is it
of course
I thank my honorable friend a for giving
way and ask him does he find it does he
agree with me and find it ridiculous
that the conservative party keep
claiming that they want to protect women
and children's rights given the fact
that just last night this government
undermined workers rights they want to
get rid of the Human Rights Act they
introduced the rape clause and they want
to remove us from the European Court of
Human Rights is it not the case that if
you want to defend rights you get them
as far away from this lot as possible
yeah absolutely absolutely Mr Speaker
and my honorable friend has made an
incredibly important point in respect of
that legislation last night because it's
not just in relation to the grr whereas
the UK government is seeking to overturn
and ignore Scotland's democratically
elected politicians that's also true of
last night's legislation in relation to
the right to strike because and I'm not
making any Grand assumptions here I
would assume West's wholehearted
confidence that an overwhelming majority
of parliamentarians in Hollywood would
be opposed to the legislation that is
being put forward by the UK government
in terms of the right to study but Mr
Speaker that is going to be ignored too
just starts on Wednesday tomorrow we're
going to have legislation before this
house in relation to the 4 000 pieces of
EU legislation which this UK government
wants to throw into the wind legislation
which puts our food standards
legislation that puts workers rights oh
that's the legislation that puts
overwhelming power in the hands of Tory
ministers unelected in Scotland of
course to do as they please now the
Scottish Parliament has been clear once
again it opposes that Mr Speaker but
yeah that too is going to be ignored
Scotland's democracy I go ignored and
ignored
grateful to my right honorable friend
for giving way and of course he's making
the powerful point about the fact that
this is in its core just an attack on
the rights of the people in the Scottish
Parliament but these these comments that
he's just made about the attacks on the
parliament have also been repeated and
echoed by the Welsh labor first Minister
Mark Drakeford who's called this
intervention today this section 35
interference he's called that a
dangerous move isn't it the case that
there's a deafness not only in this
place but on those benches next to us
from the labor party about how dangerous
these moves are for democracy across the
nations of the UK
Mr Speaker it appears that Mark
Drakeford has more of a backbone than
the vast majority of the Parliamentary
labor party put together and they could
do well to learn from his views in
respect of that but Mr Speaker I was
making the point
I was making the point that democracy
matters and that this UK government is
seeking to consistently ignore
Scotland's democracy I mentioned the
right to strike and of course I
mentioned EU attained law bill but it's
also true in respect of brexit as a
whole 72 of Scots want to rejoin the
European Union yet this UK government
and indeed this labor party have
absolutely no interest in that position
whatsoever
of course
I know he's not had an opportunity to
look at the statement of reasons some
because it's 57 paragraphs of which
you've just been served up I've had a
quick chance to have a look at this and
can I say to my honorable friend maybe
not bother having a look at the city
because it's spacious it's hypothetical
and it's purely informed and what
example of that Mr Speaker there's an
equal pay you seem to believe that a
trans man would take advantage of the
opportunity to be paid less
how did you think of that
Mr Speaker I've not obviously had the
opportunity to look at that myself but
if that is the case it is a complete an
utter embarrassment and it shows that
just as this secretary of state was
unprepared today in relation to this
matter so too his is government in
relation to the arguments that they are
putting forward I'm a little bit
embarrassed for them in this regard of
course
and he's been incredibly generous and I
just want to point out on page 1.4 uh
one point I think is particularly
concerning and it it says in relation to
those uh
points that the government are trying to
take out of the legislation that they
have concerns with taken together these
amendments remove any requirement for
third party verification or evidence
from the process now
if I'm not wrong when I came out I did
not have to seek verification from
anybody to be a lesbian so I do not
understand why we are treating trans
people as if they are applying for some
kind of arbitrary inanimate thing you
know this is about their identity it's
about their lives and it's about their
livelihoods and we should treat them
with the dignity and respect that they
deserve yeah yeah so speaker you'll be
unsurprised to know that very much agree
in that regard but if I may return to
the points I was making a respect of
democracy no uh in relation to democracy
as I said the right to strike the EU
legislation brexit but also also
importantly Mr Speaker Scotland's right
to choose as we found towards the end of
last year and of the father of the house
wishes to awaken from his slumber
no Mr Speaker he does not appear to
awaken from his Slumber
um very distracting to see that in front
of you in a democratically elected
Parliament Mr Speaker if we are to
reflect upon democracy Scotland last
year was denied its right to choose it's
right to choose by this UK government
now the Supreme Court was clear that we
don't have the power under the
Constitutional settlement to have a
secondary Independence referendum
irrespective of the views of the people
of Scotland and yet the only answer the
only answer that this UK government can
give to any question in relation to that
is no no you cannot have your say so no
matter which way we turn no matter which
issue it is of the day this UK
government is not interested in
Scotland's democracy but Mr Speaker
let's look in closer detail at the
conservative party position in relation
to that when it I'll give away
I'm forgiving we is it not the case
have any legal basis in which to
challenge this legislation and the
simple fact is that the Secretary of
State for Scotland has opened himself up
to judicial review of this because he
will simply find that he has no
modification of their existing equality
act and there is no examples within this
outline that indicate where he has
justifiable reasons for outlining this
section 35 orders
and Mr Speaker I think the secretary of
state has opened the box so it opened
himself up to many things ridicule
amongst them of course first failure to
to see the blindingly obvious but if I
may just revert back to my previous
point in perspective The Wider
conservative position in relation to
this let us be clear and then no doubt
whatsoever that the conservatives are
seeking to utilize this issue for a
cultural world nothing more and nothing
less because this is the dying Embers of
a failing government that sees the polls
that knows that it's on is we have the
knows that members are going to lose
their seats and in our last gas attempt
to create the vision they are using some
of the most vulnerable people in society
to create a cultural World absolutely
friends very kind he's absolutely right
on that point and we were accused
earlier on in the debate in the SNP of
trying to use this as a vehicle to
create a constitutional Schism and
conflict but in actual fact the SMP like
all the other parties in Hollywood that
voted this through in the Scottish
Parliament had a mandate from the
electorate in Scotland is he concerned
like I am that that government over
there has no mandate from anybody for
this action that they're taken
I absolutely sure the the views of my my
honorable friend and deeply concerned
deeply concerned about that and also
deeply concerned about the culture war
that they are seeking to score to stoke
Mr Speaker but let's Also let's also
importantly reflect upon what we have
here it's a conservative government
which as I said hasn't been elected in
Scotland since
1955 but it's perhaps most intriguing
that what we have Mr Speaker as a
Secretary of State for Scotland who we
know in the coming months we'll be
walking out of this place but he'll not
be walking anywhere else but a warm to
the undemocratic House of Lords Mr
Speaker Baron Jack as he will come to be
known it's time to tell Scotland's
democratically elected parliamentarians
what they can and can't do whilst at the
same time knowing that he is going to
end up in an unelected chamber shame on
him and shame on his conservative
colleague I will give with you
why does The Honorable gentleman think
the gender recognition act has been such
a protracted dispute in the Scottish
Parliament and has so divided the
Scottish national party
I I
don't actually agree with him on this Mr
Speaker I think it's a healthy thing in
democracy for discussion to be had
within a parliament and that's exactly
what's happened in Hollywood and it may
have escaped his notice but I will
repeat it uh because parliamentarians
from each and every party in Hollywood
voted in favor of this legislation the
question to him and his colleagues is
why they are seeking to overturn
Scotland's Democratic view in this way
and I'm more than happy to invite them
back in to answer on that specific point
he's not interested in answering on that
specific I've been very generous uh so
far but Mr Speaker but of course this
isn't just about the conservatives this
is about the labor party too should they
arise from their seats and remove the
splinters on this particular topic
because this is this is the party who
released a document last year from
Gordon Brown which was meant to put
Devolution front and center something
which critics like myself said we've all
heard it before it's not going to happen
and when Scotland's Parliament is under
attack from Westminster where are the
labor party nowhere to be found
very grateful this is the final time
I'll intervene in The Honorable
gentleman I wonder if he can tell us do
all his SMP MPS here in the UK
Parliament support the smp's gender
recognition format
I tell you what my colleagues support Mr
Speaker and that is enabling the people
of Scotland to make decisions over their
future without interference from his
Westminster government so Mr Speaker
we've heard it we've heard it all from
the conservatives before in terms of
their culture where we know that the
labor party are growing back under care
under the leader of the opposition from
their support for the lgbtq plus
community in relation to this specific
topic and it's deep play deep play
disappointing to hear that that is the
case and when we go to the Scottish
electorate again not only will we have a
labor party which is against the biggest
issue that dominates Scottish politics
at this moment Scottish independence not
only are they against Scotland having
its view in respect of our membership of
the European Union they're also also
supportive of the UK Parliament
overriding holy Spirit shame on them to
Mr Speaker but Mr Speaker
grateful once again for my old
girlfriend for uh giving away isn't the
desperate political Act of this Tory
government grabbing around for one last
dying Ember of distraction and producing
this vacuous document as an excuse isn't
it an example of desperation but isn't
it also an example as he's been
outlining of desperation to get into
prayer that the labor party won't even
take a position to support Devolution
the Devolution they were supposed to
Champion in the first place
absolutely absolutely Mr Mr Speaker and
I'm absolutely confident that the people
of Scotland will be watching and
listening to Weaver's position in
relation to us but let's let's not I'm
more than happy to to let the honorable
gentleman and I've been a Visa wishes no
he doesn't he doesn't wish to he just
wishes to chant off from a sedentary
position Mr Speaker but we heard we
heard yes of course
which appears to be about democracy and
in some respects I can see the the power
of His argument but I'm a bit confused
because it seems to me that the SNP with
representatives from Scotland voted for
the Scotland act and fall in section 35
measures that are being used today and
that furthermore the fact that they can
be used today in the UK Parliament is
because Scottish people voted to remain
within the UK in a referendum just in
2014.
well so I thought you respect Mr Speaker
I think the honorable member is is
missing the point the democratically
elected members in Scotland's Parliament
have voted for legislation within a
devolved competency and the UK
government her party are seeking to
remove that or to block that legislation
that's simply not fair and it's not
Democratic Mr Speaker anyway she
performed but what comes next what comes
next from these continual Democratic the
the continual Democratic deficit that we
experience variants on these here
Islands I think it's actually time and
it's incumbent for reasonable reasonable
unionists of which I think there are
many I don't see very many in front of
me Mr Speaker but which I think there
are many in society to come
to come forward
of course
my honorable friend forgiving we in part
two of this flabby document The Heading
is adverse effects of different GRC
regimes across the UK If there is no
allowance of different GRC regimes how
come gender recognition is devolved in
the first place
it is indeed a very powerful and
eloquent point from my honorable
colleague as always but the point of of
what comes next is incredibly important
where do we go
where do we go when Scotland's
Parliament and our views and our purpose
is just being ignored by Westminster
what are we to do what are people in
Scotland to how are they to respond to
that when are a reasonable unionists
going to stand up and say you know what
this isn't on
if you believe in this Union of equals
then you'll put the Scottish Parliament
first I don't see that I don't hear that
in Westminster and this is the clearest
example of that and it's a very rare
occurrence I will indeed I'm very
grateful to him for giving it a really
powerful speech and really bringing the
the real Democratic deficit
um really from and Center for people but
as well as the huge disappointment that
I'm sure we all feel at what the UK
government the the Tory government are
doing is he disappointed
um if I tell him the the UK labor party
will it is reported not challenge this
intervention at all two the great
disappointment of a number of their
Scottish MSP colleagues and that these
colleagues of theirs are deeply
disappointed and no wonder that's the
case
just just as we are looking for a
reasonable unionists Mr Speaker they're
clearly not found on these adventures
and if the honorable member of The
Shadow Secretary of State wants to
clarify that that's not the case then
he's more than happy to do so I'll be
unsurprised if he doesn't but Mr Speaker
the point I was weakened of course I
love it reluctant to be goaded by the
SMP but nonetheless here we are
um look just to be clear I certainly
wanted to make sure that there is a
proper gender recognition plan across
the whole of the United Kingdom because
I'm sick and tired of people setting
women's rights against trans people's
rights that's where I want to get to and
I'm looking for solutions to that
problem not anything else I I do respect
the sincerity with which as The
Honorable member delivers his points in
that regard and that's the other
honorable members nodding well if that's
the case I'm sure that the honorable
member will support us because we have a
solution in Scotland that solution is a
legislation that has been put forward in
the Scottish element which is received
Democratic support in the Scottish
parliament in which this UK government
has blocking and he should share my
anger and the anger of his I hope
colleagues in the Scottish parliament in
relation to this particular point but Mr
Speaker it's it's a rarity in this place
and I'm sure she'll forgive me in this
regard that I agree with some of the
comments for the member from Edinburgh
Edinburgh West Mr Mr Speaker but I think
when we were hearing from her earlier in
respect of the difficulty that this is
causing her in respect of the Union that
is the sort of voice that we need to
hear at this moment in time from those
reasonable unionists about where they
seek to go
because if this is a union of equals as
it is portrayed if Scotland's Parliament
is to be the most powerful devolved
legislature in the world as we're often
told that it is
then why is this section 35 order being
used
of course
grateful once again from giving we he's
talking about reasonable unionists and
said that he couldn't see any on these
benches but of course there are
reasonable unionists who have been on
this bench these benches would it be
interested in the words of Jed Killen
former labor MP who said the idea that
one man elected by 22 000 people can
overturn the devolved legislation
brought in by the Scottish Parliament
and supported by the vast majorities of
our msps is outrageous and surely will
not stand up in court it's indeed Mr
Speaker that that is very much the case
and whilst we're on that point of
reasonable unionists I want to reflect
upon the words of Donald Duck in
relation to the Scottish Parliament Mr
Speaker because this is after all what
we are talking about
he said Walter Scott wrote that the only
mat that the only the only a man was so
so dead could have no sense no feel of
his native land for me for any Scot
today is a proud moment a new stage on a
journey begun long ago and which has no
end this is a proud day for all of us a
Scottish Parliament not an end a means
to a greater end
and those two are part of our Miss woven
into its symbolic thistles are four
words
wisdom
Justice
compassion
and integrity
wisdom
Justice compassion and integrity each of
those words is reflected in the
legislation brought forward in the
Scottish Parliament it's why it received
overwhelming support from Scottish
parliamentarians it's why members from
each and every party in the Scottish
Parliament voted in favor of this
legislation and it is why it is so
important the we stand up for Scotland's
Parliament that we stand up for
Scotland's democracy and that we ensure
that the people of Scotland's views are
held in this place and I sincerely hope
and I do say this Mr Speaker in all
sincerity to the Secretary of State I
hope that he will reflect
upon the damage that he seeks to do to
his own Union in this regard
the evolved faces he shows that he does
respect Scotland's democracy and he
allows this legislation
pass as it should thank you very much Mr
speaker
thank you Mr Speaker a short time ago
the Secretary of State for Scotland made
a statement to this house regarding the
government's decision to exercise the
section 35 power of the Scotland act
with regard to the gender recognition
reform Scotland bill now for the
benefits of members who were not present
at that statement I shall summarize what
action this government is taking and why
Mr Speaker today the secretary of state
is making an order under Section 35 of
the Scotland act 1998 preventing the
gender recognition reform Scotland bill
from proceeding to Royal Ascent as the
secretary of state has said this is the
first time the power has been exercised
and this is not a decision that has been
taken likely
however it is a decision based on the
legislation's consequences for the
operation of Reserve matters across
Scotland England and Wales including on
equality legislation
the Scottish government's bill would
introduce a number of changes around
gender recognition in Scotland these
include reducing the minimum age a
person can apply for a gender
recognition certificate to 16 and
removing the needs for a medical
diagnosis and evidence of having lived
for two years in their acquired agent
gender
is it acceptable Mr Speaker for the
minister to read out the statement that
has already been made changing the order
of some of the sentences
it's up to the minister what he wishes
to say
Thank you Mr Speaker I will continue and
the bill would also mean the uk-wide
gender recognition act 2004 which
legislated for a single gender
recognition system across the entirety
of the United Kingdom now is this United
Kingdom government's assessment that the
bill would have serious adverse impact
among other things on the operation of
the equality act 2010. effects would
include impacts on the operation of
single sex clubs Association and school
associations and schools and protections
such as equal pay there are also
significant complications from having
different gender recognition regimes in
the UK p and there's also a danger of
allowing more fraudulent or bad faith
applications I'll give rates don't
remember
forgiving we if he has regard to a
holograph number 15 in what purports to
be the statement of reasons he will see
that it states there it is practically
and legally undesirable for all
including in particular the individual
holder of the GRC that a person will
have won legal sex in Scotland and a
different one in England Wales and
Northern Ireland is the minister
satisfied that this test of practicality
and legal desirability or undesirability
is one which is sufficient to meet the
test set out in section 35.
Deputy speaker well we do have um
concerns um we we believe the creation
of the two different processes for legal
gender recognition different parts of
the UK is going to create complications
which is why we have taken the action
that we have now if the honorable member
does not agree with that
um assessment with the reasons set out
in our reasons paper there is
opportunity to pray against
um the order there is the opportunity to
to to to to vote it down there's
opportunity to judicial review the
decision-making and process so there are
other options open to The Honorable
member to um raise those concerns the
government has taken its decision based
on the legal advice that we have
received We Stand by that decision The
Secret of state stands by that decision
and honorable members opposite if they
disagree have other options open to them
um to challenge that now Mr Speaker
Madam Deputy speaker I believe that I
believe and this government believes
that transgender people deserve our
respect our support and our
understanding
we have a long established world-leading
equality framework that protects
everyone including transgender people
from discrimination harassment and
victimization and Advance these equality
of opportunity for all Madam Deputy
speaker at the section 35 power has
always been part of the architecture of
the Devolution settlement because it is
an integral part of the Scotland act as
which we've heard already all parties in
this house supported at the time it
provides a sensible measure to ensure
that evolved legislation does not have
adverse effects on reserve matters
including unequalities legislation now
as the secretary of state has said it is
open to the Scottish government to bring
back an amended bill for reconsideration
in the Scottish Parliament which deals
with the concerns of this government and
many many others have raised about the
legislation and the impact that it will
have I'll give way to The Honorable
member for um badner Spades
okay very much Madam Deputy speaker the
ministers giving it away the
government's got concerns well there we
have it the conservatives had their
objections voted down in the Scottish
Parliament so he's using the device of
section 35. quite honestly the statement
of reasons is not worth the paper it's
written on and he knows that he can use
these parliamentary majority and any
praying motion to strike down an act of
the Scottish Parliament what price
Scottish democracy what price the right
of the Scottish Parliament to enact
legislation based on the majority in
that Parliament based on a mandate given
by the people of Scotland that this
government is going to throw away
because of this government this
Parliament knows better and equality of
equals Mr mother deity speaker you have
to be joking yeah
Madam Deputy speaker um as I have made
clear repeatedly the Scotland act always
intended that in these moments where
there was unintended consequences of
legislation being passed by the Scottish
Parliament impacted across the United
Kingdom section 35 gives us the
opportunity to act in this way the
Scotland the the the the letter from the
Secretary of State to the first minister
is clear about the amendment script that
can be made to the bill to allow it to
be approved by the Scottish Parliament
and to meet the concerns in terms of the
impact it's going to have to other parts
of the um UK If there's got to we very
much want to work with the Scottish
government constructively to secure
those amendments to that bill to ensure
the legislation can pass which meets our
concerns so we do hope the first
minister in the Scottish government will
um bring back the amended bill for
reconsideration by the Scottish
Parliament Madam Deputy speaker I hope
that the members honorable members
opposite the right honorable and
honorable members opposite will
acknowledge that the United Kingdom
government has set out its desire to
work together with the Scottish
government so we can find a constructive
way forward to amend this bill so that
it can pass by the Scottish government
and reach Royal ascents
[Music]
Secretary of State Scotland in Murray
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
and I think the
time that the minister took when
responding to the so24 shows you that
the government really don't have very
much to say on this particular issue or
maybe he didn't get the statement of
reasons either in terms of what the
government but actually proposing can I
start Madam Deputy speaker by just
restating again that this labor party is
the party of devolution and the party of
equality and it won't be lost on many
that the two bills that we're debating
to do the Scotland that and the
equalities that and they did the gender
recognition are all labor party bills
that we brought in in the investment
advancement of devolution and the
quality in this country and it's very
difficult to conclude anything other
than today's debate being about two
governments so in incapable of working
it together I read or skimmed
I I read and I read and skimmed the uh
13 pages of the reasons I mean the fast
that we've had to even try and get these
reasons today is part of this uh debate
and when I got to the end my initial
reaction was well what is the government
going to do about it
because they can't just bring an
unprecedented section 35 order to this
house to then lay out reasons but then
get to the end of those regions and
decide what we're going to do about it
as we stand here today the gender
recognition bill in Scotland is dead
unless both governments can come
together and resolve the issues or
perceived issues or otherwise
I'm happy to I just wonder whether my
friend has looked at paragraph three I
think it is because the minister was not
who was not taking interventions earlier
was suggesting that all the government
has to do in Scotland is bring forward a
bill with amendments so far as I can see
it would have to come forward with a
bill that doesn't have anything in it
that's the only Bill that the the
Westminster government would accept
isn't it if you go by these um the
Amendments suggested in paragraph three
that's where we get to the Crux of this
process of Rhonda made a similar Point
earlier about wanting to make sure that
trans rights and women's rights are
protected in this country and doing it
properly and this is certainly not the
way to do it so we now have a process
whereby I suspect the and we know the
first Minister and the Scottish
government will take the UK government
to court on the basis of these reasons
and their unseen legal advice and then
the courts will have to decide if these
reasons that they've put forward are
actually legitimate and indeed
reasonable in terms of the bar they have
to reach that there would be adverse
consequences on reserved legislation and
I think in actual fact at the end of
that process we might be in a a
situation whereby at the courts are
going to have to decide to resolve these
arguments because both governments are
unwilling to do so together I'm happy to
reach the honorable lady I thank the
shadow Minister for giving way is he
concerned like me that gender
recognition is devolved and yet half of
the blather in here is that it conflicts
with the 2004 act that's the whole point
of devolution is that you can actually
change legislation in Scotland in a
devolved policy area yeah
that's a very helpful intervention
because it is the case that the first
um section 14 the first category of
adverse effects talks about at different
regimes across the United Kingdom well
that to me suggests that the government
doesn't want this devolved there are
other issues such as abortion and other
issues that would have cross-border
implications that are devolved and but I
would gently just say and also in
response to the honorable lady that
Donald your designed section 35 for the
very question she has just asked it was
to allow the Scottish but well I mean
she does say if you don't maybe
repeating but not for this issue Donald
you didn't envisage all the issues that
would come through Devolution was always
a journey for the labor party and will
continue to be so
um but the key point I think in making
it in this is that section 35 was put
there to enable the Scottish Parliament
to be able to legislate and devolved
areas that may have an impact on the
rest of the UK but section 35 was to be
used as a last resort it's what it says
for when there might be some conflict so
if the first adverse effect in the paper
is that they don't want different
circumstances under gender recognition
certificates between Scotland and the
rest of the UK then surely they're
saying it should not be devolved and
have to give it
so obviously he's read what really
should be calling the clutch and it
throws reasons rather a statement of
reasons he mentioned a judicial review
and I'm not a lawyer but I'm sure
um I'm like making rig Dash and you see
how weak he's got UK government
arguments are so in that basis and he
believes in the protection of devolution
the Scotland should be able to do things
differently surely he agrees with us the
UK government should drop this action
now and actually uh the labor party
should be full Square behind the scotch
Parliament on this
but the point that The Honorable
gentleman forgets is this is going to
end up in the courts regardless because
the section 35 is being brought forward
anybody who prays against the section 35
gets a debate in a vote the vote's not
going to be won you said yourself the
other majority of 80 a working majority
of perhaps 100 on this issue and
therefore it will have to be settled in
the court and can I just say that as
much as I don't want this constitutional
battle to be on the backs of trans
people and women's rights as well it
would be quite good if the coach did
settle these issues because maybe we
could move on with substance and do what
is right by trans people for equality in
this country I was going to give way to
The Honorable member for otley and
shipment
as the Chinese Minister for giving away
because it can I take him to a paragraph
number 20 in the for reported statement
of reasons it sees that one of the
barriers that would be encountered is
existing I.T infrastructure can The
Honorable gentleman tell me if he's ever
come a case across the case 4 will
apparently law has to be designed to fit
I.T infrastructure rather than I.T
infrastructure being designed to fit the
law
well it's it's a it's a valuable
intervention I'm glad Madam speaker I'm
getting all the questions on these
adverse effects when in actual fact it's
a government's document but you're
absolutely right and what I think we've
missed in this entire debate over the
last few months is the fact that people
in this country currently have gender
recognition certificates just under a
different process where I.T systems have
to deal with that particular purpose so
whether how you get to a gender
recognition certificate is the argument
here not how you implement it because we
Implement them already
I'm very grateful just on the substance
and on the issue of how you get a gender
recognition certificate for me one of
the key things is that we take this
suggestion that it's a pathology out of
the process I want I don't want it to
feel like we are treating trans people
as if they have a pathological condition
isn't that the key thing that we need to
change
uh yes I agree and and that that should
be part of this argument and we should
be taking the the the the pathology
offers out of this this isn't a medical
disorder
um that we're dealing with here and that
should be part of the discussion but of
course all of these I wish we were
having a debate about all these things
because actually we should be rather
than having a constitutional debate
between two governments that don't want
to resolve these issues but want to
fight about it in different in different
ways yes I'm happy to give away if
Madame Deputy speaker along with me I'm
very grateful to the shadow Minister and
he's uh
seeking to cast this um conflict or
attention whatever you want to call it
as being between two governments but in
actual fact depending on how the labor
party decide to act this is a a conflict
and attention between uh two parliaments
because there is cross-party support for
this uh bill in the Scottish Parliament
from the liberal Democrats the greens
the SNP and the Scottish labor party
whereas in this house it's simply the
conservatives who are standing in the
way of this can you advise how the labor
party will move on this yeah yeah but
the honorable gentleman's completely and
utterly fundamentally wrong about that
point what we're dealing with today is a
debate between the UK and Scottish
government this is what's in the
legislation of the Scotland Act of 1998
so what we're actually dealing with
today is a debate between two well it
has to be resolved by the two
governments account if you want the
labor party to try and resolve this then
we're happy to take the seats of
government either in the Scottish
Parliament here but it's got to be
resolved by the UK and Scottish
governments that's the black and white
of this particular of this particular
issue
I'll give the I'll give way to honorable
lady whilst his colleague is chanting in
the background nonsense
for giving away and I
characterized some of what we've heard
today but I I need to say to him that
the labor party if they see that they
don't have a role in this if he doesn't
think that they ought to have a view or
an opinion or take a position then he
needs to make that very clear because
his colleagues in the Scottish
Parliament do have a view they did vote
for these Provisions as did members of
the SMP members of the liberal Democrats
and indeed some Scottish conservatives
so I think you should stop being I think
a bit disingenuous and and be clear
where did liver Party stand all is are
they going to defend the rights of the
Scottish Parliament to act or not yeah
well I'll tell you exactly where we we
stand we want this legislation to work
at this moment in time the legislation
the legislation at this moment in time
is dead and it's dead because well the
normal lady says from certain position
because of them the bottom line here is
that and and The Honorable member for
Aberdeen said quoted Donald you're at
Great length and Donald J will be
turning in his grave at the moment in
terms of what's going on in terms of the
evolution in Scottish politics because
Donald you're created the section 35
process for the very reasons The
Honorable lady has just said it's a
process to enable
cross-border problems to be resolved now
let me finish the previous Point first
now you've come the government have come
forward with 13 pages that they think
adversely affects a uk-wide legislation
I think it's thin I haven't had a chance
to look at it straight the way through
well it might be rubbish but there are
there are concerns for that people have
had that we either have to alleviate or
bring people with them what the s p have
forgotten about this entire process and
we're very experienced at this because
we do all the time when you're doing
major equalities legislation you've got
to bring people with you and if it means
that we've got to get people around the
table and no you shouldn't bring people
with you so people raise concerns you
should just say that you should just
dismiss them no this is me seeing it a
qualities legislation is difficult and
you've got to bring people with you now
these adverse effects might be rubbish I
think as I've already said initial
glance I think they are a pretty weak
and pretty flimsy but the courts are
going to have to decide whether they'll
be like this or not because that's where
it's going to that's where it's going to
go well and the Scottish Parliament have
the right to pass this legislation under
the because it's devolved but they'll
also the Scotland that protecting the
Scottish Parliament has a mechanism and
they are written by Donald Duo to ensure
that our cross-border concerns those are
dealt with and that's the way it is uh
in terms of this particular process
Madame David I haven't gone
even through the first bit well I'm
going to give away to The Honorable
gentlemen if he will apologize for
saying we were weasels before and I hope
he's gone back and read my speech which
is not what I said during my
contribution during the statement with
the greatest respect
um what I'm hearing from him now is that
he neither supports the position of the
Scottish Parliament nor does he support
the position of the government
and he says we need to have we says we
need to win public support how much
public supports the labor party got in
Scotland uh and is this the problem he's
got to face
um
leaving himself with nowhere to stand in
Scottish politics and falling between
stools is hardly standing up for the
Devolution settlement of which he should
be so proud that Donald you were
established
it's quite obvious that The Honorable
gentleman didn't listen to my
contribution during the statement it
hasn't listened to my contribution since
so I had no I had no idea which uh which
debate he's listening to but it's
certainly not the one that I'm
participating in at this particular
moment in in time Madame Deputy speaker
the bottom line here is and this is the
the undeniable fact whether we like it
or not the only way to resolve this
today would be for either both
governments to come together to try and
find an accommodation and I'm surprised
they haven't done so this has been on
the card since 2016. and all we're
getting knows a statement of adverse
effects uh one day 24 hours before the
expiry period of when the bill supposed
to get Royal Ascent so coming in at the
11th hour with a section 35 with 13
pages of adverse effects that haven't
been communicated or worked with the
Scottish government before now I've no
doubt the Scottish government I'm not
involved in detailed discussions at
ministerial level perhaps a labor party
will be at some point in the future but
maybe
um it takes two to tangle in these
discussions but if you genuinely want
this legislation through and the
government genuinely want to try and see
if there is any adverse effects that
could affect
um residents in England Wales and
Northern Ireland that aren't part of the
Scottish gender recognition act then
isn't it incumbent on both governments
to get together and do everything they
possibly can to try and resolve this so
we can get it on the statute book
section 35 can be removed and it can go
for Royal Ascent as was supposed to have
happened at some time ago and that's a
grim reality in Scottish politics at the
moment it's happened with the children
Rights bill where the UK government
challenged the children's rights Bill
through the Supreme Court the Supreme
Court said that certain aspects of the
children's rights Bill had overreached
under section 33 of the Scotland act and
another one of Donald Jr's sections that
he wrote into protect Evolution and the
Scottish government was asked to remove
those sections and the bill would get
Royal assent in two and a half years
later nothing has been done and that
just shows you that we are just in this
political paralysis in Scotland at the
moment where nobody can do anything
because it's turned into Political
football about the Constitution and the
trans community and others are sitting
there in disbelief today that that is
not going to be able to be taken let me
just let me just make some make some
progress I wanted Madame Davis people
because of accusations that had been
made just to go through a little bit of
what the Scottish labor party's
um response to the bill was in the
Scottish Parliament we had a multitude
of concerns with the initial bill and
nobody could have said that the initial
bill that was presented in draft of the
Scottish Parliament was in any way fit
to become final legislation but we work
constructively with the legislation
constructively with the UN rapporteur
for women and girls constructively with
the lgbtq plus community and
constructions with women's groups
concerns that they were raising about
the bill and we did put forward
amendments we got the equality act on
the face of the bill which is referred
to in a lot of the adverse effects in
the government's a document and and we
did get many other amendments to that
bill to help the uh to help alleviate
some of the concerns with the individual
part of the bill but the only way we're
going to settle these arguments now is
uh unfortunately through the puts on I
have to give away the leader of the
Scottish conservatives grateful to the
shutter score secretary for giving away
his UK leader said at the weekend that
he had serious concerns about reducing
the age from 18 to 16. however for my
Scottish conservative colleague Rachel
Hamilton brought forward an amendment to
keep the age at 18 rather than reducing
it to 16 labor msps joined with them SMP
vote that Amendment down what's his
position on the age limit in Scotland
yeah but we put in protections on the
age limit in Scotland and can I just say
to The Honorable The Honorable gentleman
we've got one uh party in here the
leader of the SMP accusing the Scottish
labor party in the ukulele party of
different positions on this we there's
nothing between the different positions
but but but Devolution but we should
have Devolution at the same time now
cares made it perfectly clear but
anasawa and his team got significant
Protections in in terms of 16 and 17
year olds including included including
the notary public issue which means you
have to swear in front of a notary
public in order for this to take a
effect and you have to get a responsible
adult over the age of 18 in order to be
able to do any of this under the age of
18. so what they
um honorable gentleman is essentially
challenging people on is not to have
different views in it and two of his own
front bench msps voted for the
legislation so people are entitled to
have a slightly different view on what
is an incredibly important subject and
and you know the only the only thing the
only thing that The Honorable gentleman
managed to do in the last week not get
both governments together to try and
resolve this was to write to me to as my
position on this bill well I would
rather they came together well we want
this we want this bill passed and we
want the section 35 resolved this is
simple and straightforward there's that
and you know we've had enough we've had
a position for some time to modernize uh
the gra we've already had the position
eloquently
um expressed by the member for everyone
down that position is still the position
that we currently have and can I just
say to the member to to the government
in terms of the member for lead Central
I think he made he made the crucial
point it goes back to the member that we
had the intervention from as well their
quality ad already exists with gender
recognition certificates
um and those spaces particularly Single
Sex species are protected under
exemptions under the equality act as we
currently sit here today and the adverse
reasons that the government are giving
us in terms of that um it's not about
the process of getting a GRC but the
process that is currently already in
place the government are all over the
place on this and it's little wonder
that they're Fanning the Flames of
people who wish to break up the United
Kingdom as the only result to be able to
uh do this Madam Deputy speaker
um as I've already said a number of to
have to give away
that
in the passing of the equalities act it
was noted then that the gra needed
reform and it needed to be
de-pathologized the party that came in
straight after the passing of the
equalities act the party currently in
government has spent over 13 years or 12
and a bit years fiddling their fingers
Fanning Fanning the Flames of fear and
hatred on this and then when the uh one
of the parliaments of this Kingdom has
taken decisive action rather than
stepping up and working to resolve it
instead they've constructed a
constitutional crisis which will benefit
their voting sorry yeah yeah thank you
madam Deputy speaker and I think that's
from the normal gentleman that's what
I've been seeing we desperately want the
legislation passed but we desperately
want to make sure that the issues raised
under the section 35 are resolved and
there's only two ways to do that either
through the courts which I think where
this is heading or for both governments
to get together we don't have the power
to be able to do either that Madam
series let me finish with this that
opinion polling shows at the
overwhelming majority of people in
Scotland just want the two governments
to work closely together in the interest
of the country and in this particular
issue and the interest of equality so
could I say to both governments these
issues are not irresolvable we can
create an environment where protections
exist for women at the same time as
strengthening the rights for Trans
people we can create a legal framework
where grc's issued in Scotland are
entirely compatible with UK wide
equalities legislation and we can have a
contribute both the Scottish and UK
governments atletic grown-ups get round
the table and resolve these at these
issues that's what used to happen that's
the way in which Donald J designed this
legislation and this government are now
I know implementing and I think
genuinely constructive discussions
between both governments let's lock them
in a room until they find their
resolution to this and don't let them
out till they find it and I can assure
you there's a way through this but
they're unwilling to take it
and before I call the next speaker just
to say that uh this debate has to finish
by uh
27 minutes past five so I'm introducing
a time limit I will start with five
minutes but it will go down after that
if if necessary Douglas Ross Madame
Deputy speaker then I speak Mr be
someone who's extremely privileged about
serving this Parliament and in the
Scottish Parliament so I'm able to bring
some points of view which were not
accurately articulated by the leader of
the SMP who is sadly at leaving the
chamber at the moment because I think it
is important because I am referring a
number of the points you made he speaks
about the legal advice we had the
situation in the Scottish Parliament
when the night before crucial amendments
were being debated
conservative msps Libra msps and indeed
SMP msps were written too by the cabinet
secretary about their amendments and
legal advice surrounding them but we're
told that legal advice couldn't be
shared yet here we had the UK government
sharing their statement of reasons with
Parliament and I think that well it's
based on legal advice and I'm just
showing I'm just showing the difference
approach by the government so it is
based on legal advice that was clear
from the Scottish secretary and also I
think it is important to recall that
although the s p leader in this place
and others have said this is a debate
that has been reaching in Scotland for
over six years that's absolutely correct
I've not yet heard and I'm willing to
take an intervention from any s p member
they can explain to me why it had to be
passed by December of last year what was
the rush in the lead-up to Christmas
that meant it had to go through the
Scottish Parliament before the end of
the year I'll give way to The Honorable
leadership I'm delighted to just remind
The Honorable gentlemen and you know
we're part of this if you few times
already today that this is the opposite
of rushed legislation this has been in
the works for six years this has been a
repeated Manifesto commitment of a
number of parties and it has been the
most consulted upon piece of legislation
you might more reasonably ask why did it
take as long as it did the point
honorable lady is missing is yes there
has been that debate for six years why
then did it have to go through stage
three and looking at amendments until
midnight one night and half past one in
the morning for it to be rushed through
before the end of the session surely if
there was that surely I woke up in a
moment but surely if there is that much
to be that much controversy and remember
150 amendments if that legislation
wasn't rushed there wouldn't have been
the need to look at 150 amendments and I
do yet wait to hear any SMP member
saying why it had to be put through in
December of last year I'll give way to
The Honorable lady does he not recall
that
his stalling yeah wasn't stalling and
indeed well well I'm sorry madam Deputy
speaker some some people may see the 12
or 15 points of order we had earlier
from SMP members was stalling I don't
believe that I believe that was
politicians making a point in Parliament
just like in this Scottish Parliament we
were looking at a 150 amendments because
the s p had rushed this through and
there's also been a lot made and I'll
give way to the right I'm grateful to
the The Honorable memory he raises the
issue of 150 amendments that's the point
because there is effective scrutiny that
took place in his colleagues and other
parties put down these amendments and
they were looked at in the correct
Manner and of course the Scottish
Parliament had to take time to do that
Deputy speaker we should be proud of
that
and I am and I am and that's why I
wanted that to be that's why I just beat
the point why couldn't we have continued
that to be into the new year what was
the big issue that meant the smk and the
greens were forcing this through by the
end of the year the last couple of
points I want to make in the process in
the Scottish Parliament is there's been
a lot said and the leader of the s p
refused to even acknowledge that while
there are members of all parties that
supported this bill there were a
significant number of SMP opponents to
the bill SMP ministers resigned in
Scotland as a result of this legislation
I'll give way in a moment but what I
would say is I gave my msps a free vote
I think that was right that they were
given the opportunity In fairness one of
our former colleagues in this place
Michelle Thompson who's now an SMP MSP
spoke about the dark arts of the whips
within her parties who were trying to
stop debate and and no no no no this was
from Michelle Thompson she used to be an
SMP MP she was speaking about the dark
arts of her her whips in this debate and
I'm just interested to know about the
SMP MPS who oppose this legislation I'm
not sure if any of them are here today
but I'm sure the honorable gentleman
will tell me that there are SMP MPS that
oppose his government's gender
recognition format thank you for
governor
we are ready to speak for the rest of
our colleagues in azamar for record that
some SNP msps voted against the grr that
that happened but the point of democracy
is it was a well of the Scottish
Parliament as a whole and it's a Well of
the Scottish Parliament that ham and his
government are trying to thwart no no
we're not and I'll come on to explain
that in a moment the last point I want
to make is Again The Honorable gentleman
who leads the SNP here spoke about this
government taking a view on the equality
act I I can only assume that modern
Deputy speaker he is unaware of the
letter to the SMP Minister who laid this
bill Shona ruberson from the equality
and Human Rights Commission dated the
22nd of September last year long before
this bill came back to the Scottish
Parliament that said there was potential
cross-border implications indeed the
equality and Human Rights Commission
said in our view there is an implication
for the operation of the equality act
2020. this isn't the conservatives or
this UK government saying it it is the
equality and Human Rights Commission and
they made that very clear to the
Scottish government and indeed to the s
p I'm really so I've now got two minutes
left so I apologize uh to to The
Honorable lady there is a lot I would
like to get through here I would have
liked to have heard from the the little
Democrat MP because it does seem in both
Hollywood and here liberal Democrat and
laborer supporting Nicholas sturgeon and
the SMP on this and I do worry that they
are treating this issue in the same we
they treated uh children and young
people with the passing of the UN
convention on the rights of children
Bill we were told then it was absolutely
essential legislation they then
legislated under the competencies of the
UK government and the UK government took
the Scottish government to court that
was controversial at the time Nicholas
sturgeon said it was an absolute outrage
yet having heard the ruling from the
Supreme Court on the 6th of October 2021
with the Supreme Court saying that
legislation was flawed it went back to
the Scottish government and it went back
to the Scottish Parliament what has
happened since the 6th of October 2021
well I can tell you on the 1st of
February 2022 the deputy first minister
of Scotland John Swinney wrote to the
Scottish secretary and said they are
looking to reintroduce this amended
legislation to the Scottish Parliament
given how important the uncrc was to SMP
members in the SMP government can any
smpmp here today tell me when that bill
will be introduced into the Scottish
Parliament
I'll give way to The Honorable lady if
she can tell me
um I'm not sure whether he was aware but
over the last two and a half years there
was this thing called the covert
pandemic which actually kept several
governments fairly busy yeah yeah not
sure if the honorable lady perhaps
hadn't heard me I was saying there was a
letter from the deputy first Minister on
the 6th of February 2022 so almost a
year ago we'd passed Omicron by then and
John Sweeney was telling us that he
would introduce that this is another
example Deputy first minister of the SMP
using legislation and vulnerable people
to promote a battle between the UK and
the Scottish government we can do far
far better than that
[Music]
order
um after the next speaker I will drop
the time limit to four minutes
um absolutely no problem with um uh
colleagues taking interventions but do
remember it leaves less time for others
to speak Ian Blackford thank you madam
speaker that's a pleasure to follow my
Highland colleague from Murray um this
afternoon you know we've had a lot today
about the passage of the the Scotland
act and it probably is worth reflecting
that the Scottish Parliament has only
been in existence since 1999 a very
different Parliament from the one that
we have here one that's elected under
very different systems the list system
that means it's very difficult for a
party to achieve an overall majority
there have been seven elections to our
Parliament the esnp have been in
government in the last four and only one
of those we've had a majority and I
think to answer some of the comments
made by my friend from Edinburgh South
is that the snpe government has always
had to try and reach a compromise with
other parties has always tried to reach
a consensus and I think over the the
course of that 23-year period it's worth
reflecting on how much has been done by
the parliament across party on the
subject of equalities we can be proud of
the journey that Scotland has been on
and my goodness Madam Deputy speaker we
can be proud of the bill that was passed
just before Christmas that gives
equality to trans people really
something that should Gladden the hearts
of all of us and when you recall what
happened in that vote just before
Christmas
msps from all parties voting for that
legislation a substantial majority of
the Scottish parliament of course
parties that were elected in the main
with a manifestal commitment of
delivering that legislation that has
been referred to a debate that took
place over a six-year period and to hear
people talking about that legislation
being rushed my goodness
but there's a very important principle
here because
you look at the SNP benches and we've
been hearing substantial numbers since
2015 and if I think back and everything
that's gone on
since that period and everything that's
happened since the 2014 referendum
we've repeatedly Been Told
that this is a family of Nations
that Scotland was to lead the United
Kingdom
that Scotland's Parliament was to be
respected
Madam Deputy speaker how many times have
we been here and seen that legislation
has been passed without the consent of
the Scottish Parliament throwing away
the soil convention that's supposed to
protect the rights of the Scottish
Parliament and default areas to give
consent we've seen it in so many times
who have seen it in the European
withdrawal act we've seen it in a single
Market act we're seeing it in the
legislation which is coming tomorrow on
EU laws
but the biggest disgrace we saw it
yesterday of course over the issue of
strikes but let me make some progress
and I will but we also need to think
about what is happening here
because this is a bill that's been
passed by the Scottish Parliament with
the Scottish Parliament has legislative
powers where the Scottish Parliament has
legitimacy and the Secretary of State
is using powers given to him under the
Scotland act to strike down an act of
the Scottish Parliament and why this
scrap of paper is simply not worth what
is written on it this is not about
interfering with the powers of the UK
government and interfering with acts
passed by the UK government this is
simply about interfering with the
Scottish Parliament and it makes that
point to everybody back in Scotland
the Earth Parliament has been under
attack ever since we've been here as an
SNP group since 2015 of the numbers that
we have and this is just the latest
example the UK government could have
gone to court if it wanted to in this
but it's using this legislation the
powers that the secretary of state has a
man that's going to disappear from this
chamber and end up in the unelected
House of Lords that can stop an act of
the Scottish Parliament that can strike
down an act that's been passed by a
majority of msps to strike down a bill
that has the support of members of every
political party what a disgrace and the
message to the people of Scotland
if you want to stop the Secretary of
State for Scotland interfering in our
Parliament if you want to stop the UK
Parliament denying our rights denying
our democracy then friends come with us
complete the journey Scotland must
become an independent nation
so Peter bottomly father
another speaker it's a pleasure to
listen to the former parliamentary
leader of the SNP he at least did spend
a bit more time on section 33 more than
the successor did it's certainly true
that there were three ways the UK
government could approach this uh
Scottish bill
one is to say it is deeply unpopular
with many people in Scotland do nothing
about it and let the SMP take the
political Flack which will probably
reduce the number of
members of the Scottish Parliament and
members SMP members in the UK Parliament
at Future elections that would some
people be the political Way Forward The
Better Way Forward is if there's
something substantial in the problems
that this bill May create for the UK
equalities Act is to take action either
on the section 33 or under Section 35 of
the Scotland deaf 1998. I think the
government had a choice they've chosen
to go for protective 35 and gets the
right choice and when the retinal
gentleman who just spoken refers to
what's happened since 2015. I remind him
I've reminded before that in 2017 the
SMP got 37 percent of the vote in
Scotland and the concerns got 44 of the
vote in the country as a whole I think
we'll see how this works out I think the
best way forward if I can give advice to
everybody is that we follow the
suggestion from the Secretary of State
to the first Minister that the
governments get together and work out
how to have gender recognition bill in
Scotland which is compatible and
obviously compatible with the equalities
act so that women don't feel that
they're losing any kind of their
security in any way whatsoever I commend
that to the house
Kirsten Oswald thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker you know this is really A
Dark Day for democracy I think it's
shameful that the the UK Parliament and
and the the so-called Secretary of State
for Scotland to I I know it is no longer
in this place would seek to overrule to
override the democratically elected
representatives who people in Scotland
have sent to our national Parliament it
really does show complete contempt for
the Scottish Parliament and for its
ability to pass legislation within its
areas of competence so it's no
exaggeration to call this out for what
it is it's a politically motivated
assault on our Democratic processes and
our Democratic institutions by a
right-wing Tory party that has no
compunction at all in using one of the
most marginalized groups in our society
to achieve its aims and we need to
remember what this is all about it is
about simplifying the process for people
applying for a gender recognition
certificate that is all this is about it
doesn't change the effect of a gender
recognition certificate That Remains the
Same as under the gender recognition act
2004 it only sees
proven simplify the process by which a
trans person can apply for legal
recognition of their acquired gender
that's a right that's been in place for
18 years and this bill passing
represents an important step towards
creating a more equal and fair Scotland
where LGBT people are valued and
included and empowered and I'm proud
that the Scottish Parliament voted for
that
and let's be clear the gender
recognition reform bill was passed
overwhelmingly by the Scottish
Parliament and by members from all
parties including the Tory party and
with the overwhelming support of SNP
labor rudeen and liberal Democrat msps
and all of these parties represented in
Hollywood apart from the Tories had
actually committed in their manifestos
to improving gender recognition laws
the provisions we've spoken about this
they're the most widely consulted upon
in the history of the parliament and as
well as the very Broad and wide-ranging
consultation the Scottish parlance
equality human rights and Civil Justice
committee heard from people including
the leader of the Irish senate about
experiences with similar legislation
there and it's not only Ireland we've
heard about this today these kind of
measures are in place increasingly in
countries across the world this is not
groundbreaking stuff it's inconceivable
to me that there is a good reason for us
to be arguing about it and we've heard
about all these conversations that took
place we've heard about the Amendments
we've heard about the way that it passed
through Parliament with all of these
conversations happening so on any
examination this has been a very
detailed and a very thorough process
leading up to a very clear decision and
all of that within the competence of the
Scottish Parliament so why the UK
government who is no friend of human
rights in any guys wants to step in why
they want to step in on this issue which
affects a marginalized group so much is
a mystery to me it might be the the
secretary of state from for Scotland has
a different view to me on gender
recognition reform and that's his right
just as My Views are my right but what
should not be his right as one man there
soon to be bad and Jack stepping forward
and overriding the Democratic voice of
the Scottish Parliament throwing his
weight around just because he can and
I've read the statement of reasons now
and I still can't fathom what the basis
is for this measure but I think that
whether it's on the Constitution or
whether it's on the gender issue I think
that the the court of the Secretary of
State and the courts of the government
actually are on a real sugary Peg here
whether they think about the Tory Reform
Group and what they said the chair of
the equalities committee pointing out
that this does not cut across equality's
legislation whether we look at what Andy
McKeever has said on all of these fronts
these people are making important points
which should be listened to but
fundamental to all of that is the
Democratic point the Scottish Parliament
has voted for these measures and it's
their right to do so
Alan Cairns
Deputy speaker and I Rise to contribute
to this debate as a passionate unions
like many members on this side of the
house and I am concerned about any
legislation that could undermine the
settlement that we have within the union
of the United Kingdom and I say this as
a pharmaceutical state that took a
Devolution Bill through Parliament uh
and was also in the cabinet when the
Scotland last Scotland act uh went
through uh uh Parliament as well and
having served in a devolved
Administration what I understand the uh
the gentleman objectives and the
supports that uh that the devil
administration's hope
so the starting point so the principle
of one legislature intervening on
another legislature is a very could be
could be a very dangerous precedent so
my starting point in this debate would
be to have sympathy with a Scottish
nationalist with what they are claiming
with what they're doing and to
understand the points in which some of
them are making
that it could be a dangerous precedence
but section 35
this is not about gender recognition it
is not about all of the sensitivities
that are associated with that this is
about the process of good law making or
providing Clarity and providing a
satisfaction within the equalities act
and that is something that we all should
be concerned about because of the people
that would make use of the equalities
acts because of their uh their
vulnerability and the
appalling way some of these people will
have you know some of these individuals
would have been dealt with uh previously
so the synthetic anger that comes from
the benches opposite troubles me because
the reality is that they often refer to
the courts in order to clarify the
devolved settlement and that is fine and
in order and provides ultimate clarity
and this section 35 order we all know
will still end up in the courts and so
why'd so much synthetic anger around
that because that will provide Clarity
to this as well and if they have so much
confidence in waiving this document
around saying that it is worthless well
that will be the finding in the court
so let's at least concentrate on the
good process of legislative of law
making where one legislature has respect
for the other and if there is a genuine
concern they should respond to the
invitation made by the Secretary of
State where where both leaders of
legislation and legislators can get
together to debate and discuss and seek
to deliver a positive outcome because
this is about the outcomes uh not about
the anger and the synthetic noises that
have been made that have been made by
the members opposite
so and I then want to turn to the uh the
labor party and I'm sure I'm sorry that
these shadow secretary of state is is
not uh in his place because I am really
disappointed uh by the approach that the
labor party have been taking on this uh
they've been criticizing called
different names and legitimately so and
I say that and with no I say that with
no gratification or pleasure or anything
like that because I thought the labor
party was a unionist party and would
want the law to be respected and section
35 to be used for the very reason that
they lay down but the shadow Secretary
of State taught to manufacture all sorts
of nonsense around this debate rather
than recognizing the legitimate concerns
uh that uh that exist surely the labor
party would want to see a a good
law-making process so there is a time
when process and principle matters to
secure good legislation but also I would
say to the shadow minister opposite to
secure the Union as well order Christine
Jardine thank you very much Madam Deputy
speaker and it's a pleasure to follow
the honorable member from field of
glomorgan who says he's a unionized I
have no reason to doubt that but I'm
assume that I am as well
and I would like to assure Not Only The
Honorable member opposite but the
members of the government officer and
the leader of the Scottish conservative
party that my objection to this and my
party's subjecting to this
is not to do with the fact that section
35 exists we think that that is a good
check imbalance it's not to do with the
rate of the UK government to intervene
when there is a genuine need for it it
is it this is not the time it is not the
the case and it is not appropriate
the parliament of Scotland considered
this very carefully The Honorable member
for Murray talked about the letter which
came pointing out potential differences
well potential problems are beg your
pardon with the out I wonder if it
occurred to him at all that in the year
between that or almost year between that
letter arriving and the Amendments being
placed before Parliament those were
taken into account that the legislation
that was passed by the Scottish
Parliament looked at every conceivable
situation and took it into account
I asked the Secretary of State earlier
if he could point out to me the section
of the bill which undermines my rights
as a woman my daughter's rights as a
woman all the women I know children I
know and he didn't
but we have been directed to this
document
this flimsy weak apology
of a statement of reason as the supposed
justification for this section this
section 35 or the 35 intervention and to
see it's weak it's to flatter it
those of us on the opposition benches
and some who support the government have
looked at this bill in great detail our
colleagues in the Scottish Parliament
poured over it with a fine-tooth comb
and considered 150 amendments it says on
the face of the bill that it will always
guarantee the Primacy of the equalities
act the parliament of Scotland has made
a decision a considered decision the
elected representatives of the people of
Scotland have made that decision on
behalf of a very vulnerable section of
our society they have made progress
towards a society where those people
feel respected honored
treasured in a way that perhaps they had
not done before and I am grateful to my
colleagues in the Scottish Parliament
for having done that for my fellow Scots
and I have to say I am disappointed in
the government of the United Kingdom
that they have taken this completely
inappropriate opportunity
stage a constitutional
crisis a constitutional confrontation
with the Scottish Parliament because
please be sure it is the Scottish
Parliament it is not the Scottish
government
and I would ask
that they carefully reconsider the
damage that they are about to do
to the unionist cause
in Scotland if they do not respect the
wishes of the Scottish Parliament
uh Miriam Kate thank you madam Deputy
speaker and I Rise to support the
government's decision to use it section
35 Powers with respect to the gender
recognition Reform Bill in Scotland now
like many other honorable members I'm
afraid I haven't had chance to read this
in full and in detail so I will focus my
remarks on a few key areas that I think
are significantly important firstly in
paragraph 27 the government rightly
points out the bill does not create
sufficient safeguards and I think indeed
the government is very right to be
concerned about uh fraudulent and malign
applications with the implications for
child safeguarding now this morning in
the education select committee we had
Professor Alexis J Who of course chaired
the uh inquiry into institutional child
sexual abuse and it was harrowing to
hear the stories of Decades of child
sexual abuse through our institutions
across this country and there's one key
feature of that abuse which is that
Predators will exploit any loophole they
can find to get access to children and
that is I'm afraid what will happen with
this bill we shouldn't be asking how
easy is it for someone who's
uncomfortable with their sex to obtain a
GRC we should be asking how easy is it
for a predator to get access to children
and I'm afraid this bill would make it
vastly easier for a predator to get
access to children to change their sex
to change their gender with an eye to
exploiting loopholes of accessing
children and women in particular no I'm
good I've only got four minutes so
um if the naivety that this has been
written with is absolutely astounding
and hugely worrying I think also the the
reduced reduction of the age limit to 16
is significant safeguarding risk human
brain does not end development until
about the age of 25 you can't drive a
car when you're 16. there are awful lot
of things that you're not allowed to do
legally when you're 16 because you
cannot assess the long-term implications
on your welfare changing your legal
gender with a potential route to
long-term changes to your fertility your
sexual function your health is not
suitable for 16 year olds there's a huge
safeguarding risk section A paragraphs
30 and 48 mentioned membership on the
grounds of sex and Single Sex spaces sex
matters did a report recently uh looking
at the impact on Single Sex spaces and
the ability of men to access them
through through changing their their
gender the one thing women say is I
never went back I never went back to
that swimming pool I never went back to
that counseling class for many women the
the Dignity of being a women-only space
of knowing that there's no men there are
no men that are going to be that is so
important we will see a chilling effect
on important Single Sex uh rights if
this goes through
um and I think you know as a woman I
fully understand the threats to dignity
and safety that this poses because it
will change the social contract in this
country we recognize that in toilets and
changing rooms in public spaces there
are areas where only women allow are
allowed I had an experience recently in
a restaurant where a man dressed as a
woman what walked into the toilet so I
was on my own in the toilet so he stood
behind me and stared at me into the
mirror looking at me in my eyes now I
have no idea if he intended me any harm
but but but my instinct my evolved
Instinct as a woman was to be frightened
because unlike almost any other species
women are far less powerful than men we
can't defend ourselves that's why we
have no it's a fact the difference in
strength between men and women is
phenomenal that's why we have separate
sex categories for sport women are
involved to be wary of men in Intimate
spaces that's why we have single sex
spaces they must continue to exist for
the safety and privacy for women this
threatens that social contract finally
it threatens the understanding of our
law which should be based on fact and
you cannot change your sex any more than
you can change your place of birth or
who your parents are now I fully
understand the complex arguments
involved in this and we should treat it
with compassion but if the law is not
based on fact then how can we trust the
law that is why the government is
absolutely right to serve this notice
order Lloyd Russian Boyle could just be
that speech was probably one of the
worst transphobic dog whistle speeches
that I've heard in an awful long time
the idea of linking trans people with
Predators frankly is disgusting and you
should be ashamed
oh no calm down
yes
way to you
or anyone else to the to the honorable
member to The Honorable member now on
the substance of this ignoring that
horrible speech that we have just heard
actually
order spew to bottomless did chair
transphobic in the previous speech
I have to say
um to the father of the house that
um you know different
um colleagues different members of this
house are going to interpret speeches in
different ways and I suggest that what
we do is move on quickly I think the
honorable gentleman needs to calm down
moderate his language and move on to the
substance of the debate otherwise I will
ask him to resume his seat Lloyd Russell
thank you madam Deputy speaker it is it
is difficult when we're talking about
these emotional matters but the reality
of this is this section 35 is the new
Tories section 28. it is their
continuation of a war against a group of
people their culture war that they want
to pursue and they think it will
Advocate Advantage them in the polls
that's what the Australian conservatives
thought as well that's what the the
Republicans in the U.S thought that I
trust it will not because the people do
not like the bigotry that we hear from
the other side so what it is bigotry I
will give away it is bigotry what we
just heard I recognize the individual
feels
um could I could I just say to The
Honorable gentleman that
um we are very short of time I hope that
if he takes an intervention he will
stick to the four minutes Alicia cares I
recognize that the orange feels very
strongly about this but I would ask him
to caution labeling a party is solely
one thing because it is the conservative
party colleagues who have led for a
conversion therapy ban that today has
been announced when I was elected no
other MP talked about it for seven
months and we have today delivered it so
I would caution him please do not label
all members of certain size of the house
to be transformed we've got homophobic
and I would also challenge that anyone
should be labeled that within this year
yeah yeah I I will say that there are
some very honorable members on all sides
of the house including on that side who
have resisted the moves from the
government when when trans conversion
therapy was removed pushed fit to get
back in and and their work is to be
applauded but what this report says in
reality is there is no amendment that
this government would accept that they
would allow to pass what this flimsy
piece of paper indicates is that the
only Bill that they would accept is the
current UK law and anything that
deviates from it would be blocked well
I'm afraid that is an undermining of the
very concept of devolution just be
honest just just be honest and come and
say that you want to remove the devolved
competencies of this area from the
Scottish Parliament and you want to
return them back to Westminster at least
that would be an honest debate rather
than this dog whistle debate around the
safety of children which frankly is not
correct now of course there will be
there will be concerns of course this
bill will not be perfect no bill is
perfect but one of the key principles in
my job I think all of our jobs is to not
let the enemy of
the flaws that might have come from it
and then they could have amended it the
Scottish Parliament could have made the
actions to me because all bills are
living documents and practical but
instead the and and I say this as a gay
man who loves all male spaces sometimes
finds that actually the liberation of
having those spaces is important and I'm
sure that many women feel the the safety
of all women's faces is important to
them but this bill does not change that
law one bit GRC certificates exist at
the moment we have already a system
where you can change your passport and
your driving license without a GRC
certificate going into a toilet or a
public facility or a refuge is not
contingent on a certificate at all so
all of those arguments are bogus and to
continue a bogus argument knowing that
it is bogus is I'm afraid a form of
bigotry
uh Craig McKinley and speaker I'm rather
concerned because the honorable member
from uh Brighton Kempton might have a
seizure at the end of my speech but uh
we'll do our best to keep him calm
speaker
um I as we start this I'm I have the
words of the right honor of The
Honorable member from Murray ringing in
my ears that before or as this
legislation was making its way to the
Scotland Parliament that you received
that they received no legal advice that
we have received here today in this you
know good form of document whether you
agree with it or not it is available for
our
um analysis but it seems that as this
legislation went through the Scottish
Parliament no such advice as to whether
section 35 their overtones and issues or
whether the equality act 2010 had any
overtones and issues now I do have
issues with the whole concept but I'm
not going too straight into that too
much but on the age of 16
I I find this scarcely believable that
even in Scotland
a 16 year old can't drive a 16 year old
can't buy alcohol 16 year old can't buy
cigarettes
please oh they can vote in Scotland a 16
year old can vote and they can get
married without parental consent and
join the armed forces so I would I would
urge The Honorable member to to take
Credence of the actual situation in
school I was going to cover the things
that you can do at 16. I do understand
that in education in Scotland uh the
access of the Armed Forces to actually
encouraging a future and a career in the
armed forces is actively discouraged
which is taking a lot of people away
from what is a credible and superb
future employment but in Scotland uh I
always like to give the sun bed rule
can't even go on a sunbed in Scotland
and yet here we can't contract and yet
here we are we all wanted to do lots of
things at age 16 and I will declare to
the house I'd rather wanted a a tattoo
and an earring at age 16 and here we are
at age 56 and I'm damn pleased I didn't
go up that route but what it does mean
when I lay on the beaches that most
people now sort of point at me and say
look at that there's a guy without a
tattoo on this beach it's
now the other safeguards that I'm
concerned about is about sex offenders I
mean are we really that naive to think
those that are so minded
will not exploit some of these rules
to do things that we know that they will
be minded to do are we really that naive
that we are left to think that people
will do the right thing in all
circumstances
now I am an absolute libertarian
conservative I have no interest how
people want to live that is a matter for
them I have completely no interest and I
don't bring my opinion to this place for
legislation that is not my interest or
concern and I I you know steadfastly do
that people can do exactly as they
please I'd be delighted to with them I I
do question some elements of this bill
in particular why the amendment making
clear that anyone going through being
charged and trial for sexual offenses
should be excluded I think that was
Madness but I would just question one
point of his argument what evidence is
there that by a man becoming a woman he
somehow has more privileged access to
Children than he currently does as a man
this is what I cannot understand within
the argument
[Music]
um
The Honorable lady hasn't been here for
the whole of the debate I am getting
concerned that people who've been here
are not going to be getting so I am
going to say that they the net I will
reduce the time limit now to three
minutes but I would urge The Honorable
gentleman to bring his remarks to her
clothes because otherwise he'll have
taken a lot more time I I thank my right
on a friend I could go into quite a
story actually about
um
I mean a nurse a a transsexual woman
that was presented to a constituent of
mine and the daughter for a an intimate
examination but it's a story for another
day uh that I haven't got time to
examine here today
but I I'm concerned that the potential
for obtaining a GRC is much easier and
much reduced rather than what I think
has been a well-debated and well
rehearsed and settled argument across
the UK up to this date where you know
living as an appropriate uh in a the
opposite sex or in a different sex for
two years having some medical advice and
intervention and the guarantee an offer
that you know one shall live in that way
for the rest of one's days has been a
settled will I think that's sensible I'm
fully in agreement with that and as I
say I'm a Libertarian conservative so I
you know I really don't mind what people
want to do but this is an issue about
section 35 of the Scotland act this
changes the equality act 2010 it changes
the way we live and and I support the
government Alison do this three minutes
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
and I Rise to support the right of the
Scottish Parliament to legislate and to
pause uh this government's attempts to
override the Democratic wishes over
democratically elected Scottish
Parliament We join in Scotland countries
like Denmark Malta Ireland Norway
Belgium the Netherlands Portugal Ireland
Switzerland Argentina Uruguay in New
Zealand in doing this the UK government
has not acted itself yet it's at six to
deny the Scottish Parliament the right
to do this the the very thin statement
of reasons that the government has
brought forward really is a whole loads
of supposition guesswork and nonsense uh
within this we can't possibly have
um a gender equal we kind of possibly
have this legislation in Scotland
because hmrc can't fix its systems we
can't publicly have this in Scotland
because the UK government is second
guessing the number of people that might
actually take it up we can't possibly
have this in Scotland because they're
very tiny small limited number a handful
of private schools that still offer in
Scotland a single six places my might
have a problem this is ludicrous
nonsense and very very thin but what I
do want to raise in here particularly is
a statement by all of the women's
organizations in Scotland who have
stated today too much of this debater in
this bill has been shaped by
misinformation and what the bill will
actually mean in practice the majority
of Human Rights women's and equalities
organizations in Scotland have shown
clear consistent and unified support for
this legislation throughout its seven
years in development and there's a
longer statement that is signed by
Anderson International close the gap and
gender human rights Consortium Josh
Wright Scotland National Union of
students Scotland one parent family
Scotland group crisis Scotland Scott
Street Union Congress the Scottish
Refugee Council Scottish women's Aid
scratch women's convention Scottish
women's rights Center young women's
women and zero tolerance so the UK
government ministers in this place think
they know better than these yeah experts
experts with years of experience in
dealing with vulnerable women they
really have another thing coming they
should reject their actions today they
should draw back from opposing this bill
and they should let Scottish government
get on with the business of going trans
people the rights they so richly deserve
Nick Fletcher I don't know Mr Speaker I
want to start where the SMP leader
finished off it's not in this price
sorry about that talking about wisdom
I want to ask where is the wisdom in the
removal of the requirement of an
applicant to have or have had a
diagnosis of gender dysphoria where is
the Winston in reducing the minimum age
for applicants from 18 to 16. where is
the wisdom in the period for which an
applicant must have lived in the
acquired gender before submitting an
application from two years to three
months where is the wisdom in the
removal of the requirement for an
applicant to provide any evidence that
they have lived in their acquired gender
when submitting an application
where is the wisdom in the removal of
the requirement for a panel to be
satisfied that the applicant meets the
require that meets the criteria there
may have been six years of consultation
there may have been many experts who
have gone through this but unfortunately
there has been no common sense
the only common sense that I have heard
today
and the wisdom that I've heard today is
for the Secretary of State to use
section 35 to protect women and children
in England
I have spoken on this subject before and
I have been vilified for saying
transgender children they are just going
through a phase only for the NHS to
write an article a few weeks later
saying the majority of children are
going through a phase
this is a toxic subject and it is now
being used by the SMP as a political
football
but I want members to remember across
this house what this is all about
there are families in this country now
where they're boys and girls are coming
home from the score and saying they are
in the wrong body
these sorts of things are being
glamorized on TV as though it's a
wonderful thing well let me tell you it
is tearing parents families and children
apart and setting children on a path
of puberty blockers
hormone Replacements and then onto
surgery
it is a disgrace what we are doing with
children and it must stop
I just hope that the parents of those
children who come home and have to hear
their children go through this show the
wisdom
and stick fast and hard to their
beliefs that they are born their child
was born in the right body and we should
do all we can in this place to protect
those parents protect women and protect
children
Neil hanvey thank you madam Deputy
speaker and I just want to make it clear
that balancing rights is not a simple
task balancing rates is complicated and
it requires proper attention we've
needed constructive discussion on
equality and rights for years but that
has been consistently dismissed and
denied this is entirely the wrong issue
for a constitutional crash it's a matter
of public record that I myself and my
party have great concerns about the
format and consequences of this bill as
it has alienated women campaigners and
Defenders of the rights of women to
access Single Sex spaces across Scotland
but there are a couple of points I want
to make from the Secretary of State's
attention a section 35 order is
absolutely the wrong approach the
Secretary of State said earlier today
that the SNP had not objected during the
passage of the Scotland built to
override the clause which has been
invoked today I have to tell him that is
simply not the case far from the section
35 override Clause being agreed to by
the SNP it was subjected to strongly
most of all by my party leader Alex
salmond
it was realized then it would cause the
very trouble it is creating now there
are two questions for the Secretary of
State and he must address them firstly
if it isn't appropriate to use section
33 will he now publish that legal advice
however exceptional to do so that is and
secondly why has the Secretary of State
not used schedule 6 part 1 of the
Scotland act as that would surely have
been a route open to him that at the
part of the ACT States schedule six part
one that in the scheduled Evolution
issues means any other question about
whether a function is exercisable within
devolved competencies or in this regards
Scotland and any other question arising
by virtue of that this act without
Reserve matters the matter was not
referred to under that schedule why
I have no concerns about trans people my
concern is and always had been about Bad
actors as mentioned earlier today
regarding uh the police case uh that's
got been in the Press today uh
um uh predators are determined and
devious and they will go to
extraordinary links to access their prey
we know that through various reports not
least the behavioral of organizations
and the lambing report about uh overly
optimistic and unrealistic views of
predators and 42 of trans-identifying
prisoners are on the female estate are
sex offenders that's not representative
of the trans Community it's a distortion
so any suggestion that people will not
use it for nefarious ends is wrong order
James Daly thank you very much indeed by
the deputy speaker can I rise in support
of the government my honorable friend
from Don Valley and more specifically my
honorable friend from peniston and
stocksbridge who is one of the most
thoughtful honorable people in this
house and the language that has been
used against my honorable friend is
typical of the language of the left for
people with deeply held
honest views and it is disc the word
disgusting was used across there it is
disgusting that my honorable friend was
treated in that way here today
now
I I think this in general Madam
netspeaker has been a good debate we
have had the normal debate every single
time my I'm in this chamber listen to my
honorable friends from the SMP no matter
what the debate we come back to
Independence one version of it or
another
and when we look at the title of this
debate here there's two things to talk
about the first is as it says up there
section 35 power now the question
therefore legal a constitutionally is
are the government entitled
constitutionally to use that power to
intervene on this decision of the cons
of the Scottish government and clearly
they are there is simply no argument
against that the equalities Act of 2010
is the is the legislation within the
United Kingdom that guarantees equal
um human rights equal rights for
everyone no matter where you live in the
uh United Kingdom this piece of
legislation from the Scottish national
party and then the 2004 act the gender
recognition act and that brings it in to
the competence of section 35 because
as it has been said previously the
secretary of state is entitled if there
are adverse effects of this legislation
and the impacts of the operation of the
equality act that result from the fact
that the garc changed the person's
protected characteristics of sex for the
purpose of the 2010 act so that clearly
does there is a legal basis to what the
government so if we go away from that
constitutionally the government are
entitled to do this we could have a
debate regarding the you know what are
the merits of one argument or the other
but the government are entitled to do
this they are the elected government of
the United Kingdom we talk and I know my
friends from the s p would prefers not
to talk like this we are the United
Kingdom and legislation like the
qualities act 2010 applies to us all now
in terms of the issues that we're
talking about here because of the
competencies because of the section 35
it brings within the scope that people
members such as me from English
constituencies can speak in respect of
this and I believe madam speak and I'm
sure I'm waiting for something from the
Live party just call me transphobic or
something I believe that 16 is too young
for these decisions to be made I believe
that this legislation is a direct threat
to uh women's rights sex and
health-based rights and especially
Single Sex bases now those are genuinely
held beliefs so the government are
entitled to do this the government share
my beliefs and they are entirely correct
in what they are doing today Charlotte
Nichols thank you madam Deputy speaker
this is a policy statement not a legal
document and one so thin that it's
absolutely translucent for such an
unprecedented unilateral action in
invoking the section 35 powers and
frankly I've been disgusted by a lot of
the tone of the debate today there are a
lot of people who I'm very interested to
hear suddenly become massive Defenders
of equality including the honorable
member from Don Valley who I remember
being in a Westminster Hall debate with
when he said that Doctor Who being a
woman was turning boys gay among other
ridiculous arguments
would you give away that is not actually
I think more than enough
yes it is yes it is I will not withdraw
it no no The Honorable gentleman must
resume his seat must resume his seat if
he wants to say a point of order he can
make a point of order
Nick Fletcher normal member to withdraw
that and refer to answer that is not
what I said that is an outright lie ah
no no no no no
uh The Honorable gentleman must
um qualify that I think he meant she may
have unintentionally uh misled the house
is that he is going to say I hope it is
yes it is it is and I hope
um with regard to the point of order
which obviously he was addressing to me
to say that he felt on a point of order
that what had been said was incorrect my
response to that is that if the
honorable lady at any point feels that
what she has said when she goes back to
look at the debate has unintentionally
misled the house that she will correct
the record and I'm taking her word for
it that she will do that
Charlotte Nichols thank you very much
Madam Deputy speaker and on checking
hand side the honorable member actually
said that Doctor Who being a woman was
turning boys towards a life of crime uh
so clearly it was a matter of misogyny
rather than homophobia however
I I am very sorry for having
inadvertently misled the house in
accusing the member in a very legitimate
comment that I made about his brand new
respect for our recurrency legislation
in having made a remark that was
misogynist rather than in fact
homophobic so I apologize for that
Omission I will not give way we've heard
more than enough from The Honorable
member today what I would like to talk
about is the substance of this piece of
paper because frankly it is an absolute
joke I will declare an interest as an
LGBT woman as someone who is myself LGBT
and exists something that's been
forgotten entirely in this debate by
people that are trying to draw a false
distinction between the rights of women
and the rights of LGBT people including
trans people I'm afraid that I don't
have the time that I would like to go
through all of the Clauses in here which
as I said are so flimsy easy as to be
ridiculous including Clause 20 which I'm
calling the computer says no clause
which as the minister the shadow
Minister referred to earlier says that
the law can't be changed because the
computer system couldn't handle it the
computer system should be changed
abide by the law not the other way
around these adverse uh potential
impacts are flimsy this piece of paper
is an absolute nonsense and as I said
there is just no justification
whatsoever for such an unprecedented
action in invoking section 35. let's see
Blackman
the next speaker I want to start with an
apology and to all of those trans people
in Scotland who had the hope that they
were going to be able to get the gender
recognition certificate that they can't
currently get because they cannot
provide thousands of pages of evidence
because they cannot go in front of a
panel because they cannot get a medical
diagnosis of gender dysphoria which the
who has said should not be necessary in
order for a gender recognition
certificate I want to apologize that
we've given them that hope and the UK
government has again dashed that I don't
know if you figure we're a room full of
CIS people talking about the lives of
trans people that is what we are doing
in this room we were talking about the
lives of other people we're talking
about rights that do not affect us in
the privileged entitled position that we
have here Madame Deputy speaker
wait I want to know why the UK
government has suddenly decided that
it's going to try and protect vulnerable
women and children Suddenly It's decided
this they didn't think this but it was
talking about the rape clause and
implementing that it didn't think this
when it was demonizing migrants and
refugees it didn't want to protect women
and children until today when it seems
like they can suddenly use this wage
issue to attack trans people to demonize
the Scottish Parliament and the Scottish
government for the decision that we have
taken the decisions that we have taken
in Scotland to try to improve the lives
of our trans constituents modern day
speaker I asked the Secretary of State
earlier I asked him what are gender
recognition certificate does he did not
have the faintest clue what a gender
recognition certificate does yet he has
got the power to veto this legislation
from the Scottish Parliament I have
looked at the statement of reasons and
it has no reasons that of any impact on
the lives of women and girls who are not
trans it does not have any impact on the
lives because it is a manufactured
grievance the labor party is absolutely
correct it's a manufactured grievance by
the conservatives they are cynically
using the lives of trans people to
create this conflict a gender Refugee
certificate does not allow you access to
bathrooms it does not allow you access
to changing rooms it does not allow you
to change your passport or driving
license you can do that without a gender
recognition certificate all it does is
allow you to live and die in dignity
once you do the correct gender on your
death certificate it allows you to
pension providers recognize your gender
it is something that trans people need
and cannot currently access because of
the massive barriers put up in the
current act devastated that people over
there are suggesting that we should roll
back on the current act even what we
should be doing is making life better
for people and improving human rights
not dismantling them
hey thank you Adam thank you speaker
like first and foremost this is an
attack in Devolution this is an attack
in elected members of Scottish
Parliament and it's an attack made by
Scottish secretary who's never actually
respected institution of the Scottish
parliament in the first place he's
always thought waste ministers more
important always thought Westminster had
Primacy over the Scottish Parliament
now the tip she seems quite scary it
tells you as well get the most powerful
devolved parliament in the world we
don't even the most powerful devolved
parliament in the UK the Northern
Ireland sellers get much better Powers
than Scotland including pensions and
rights over the union to name Victor and
then Rick Madame the speaker when you
listen to the arguments on here today
they the right wing Tori standing up
pretending to speak for women's rights
right round Tories are part of a culture
War right when Tories at the end of the
cheek to say that we're manufacture
constitutional debate how can about us
manufacture constitutional debate when
two-thirds of the Scottish
parliamentarians elected the Scottish
Parliament voted for the grr I can't go
away we don't have enough time so it's
absolutely grievance politics in a
culture war from the Tories and then we
get the clutch in its throes reason of
statement now somebody tried to say this
is legal advice it's not legal advice
everyone knows if you pay a lawyer you
can you can get a loyalty right what you
want and that's what that says a list of
bogus reasons to come up for reasons
there's quite safety temperatures to
section 35 now let's look at equal pay
equal pay sections unbelievable it's sin
transgender people are going to cause
problems we could pay because if if
somebody transgenders from it becomes a
transgender woman then they might have
been in higher pay before and that that
caused that that's going to affect the
claims they're also saying someday
actually transitioning could affect the
claim of somebody else's equal pay claim
because they can't use that person a
benchmark if you're talking
manufacturing grievance you can't make
that up and that's your fact that must
happen just now when people are ready to
go at GRC certificate so effort
settlement now the boat mine is you know
but you know if you're on the right side
of the argument when you're opposite
side of that lot there comparing to
comparing times people to Predators it's
another disgrace and one of them was
already done it but you know on your
right side the argument when Ernest
International closing up in gender
humans rate Consortium just rate
Scotland nus Scotland one parent Farm is
called rape case is called Scott Street
Union's Congress Scottish Refugee
Council Scottish women say Scottish runs
convention Scottish women's rights
Center young women's movement and Zero
Tolerance on the same side as us
question is that this house has
considered the government's decision to
use section 35 of the Scotland act with
regard to the gender recognition reform
Scotland bill as many as are of that
opinion say
aye
no
oh
near the lobby
thank you